bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream salut Fab comment vas-tu ça va ça
va et toi bonjour à tous yes
aujourd'hui du tata style donc on vous
rappelle un petit peu si vous voulez le
le
classement de du tournoi pour l'instant
je vais vous l'afficher sur le stream
donc du coup on avait Fab on avait Abdou
qui avait 6 sur 8 qui vraiment
pour l'instant défaut c'est un peu le
tournoi 6 sur 8 un point d'avance sur
Agnès guéri et Wesley Sow c'est quand
même c'est quand même assez
impressionnant en tout cas
que c'est un super joueur en rapides ou
quoi mais là en partie lente pour son
premier vrai gros tournoi comme ça c'est
ouais c'est très impressionnant ouais
c'est ça et ben du coup c'était vraiment
tu vois c'est ouais c'est pas une
attendu mais bon il avait quand même au
début complètement marcher sur le chest
tu as 960 il avait commencé avec un 8
sur 8 je crois et puis il a été quand
même champion du monde de rapides donc
c'est il a quand même fait un petit peu
ses preuves mais c'est vrai que dans un
tournoi comme ça la partie lente face à
une adversité aussi forte et ben c'est
vrai que c'est quand même une belle
surprise de le voir ici avec 6 sur 8
mais en tout cas bon là on voit vraiment
la jeunesse qui renverse un petit peu tu
vois les la hiérarchie quoi on voit
guéri deuxième slow Sow par contre 3e et
on voit du coup 45 qui vient de gagner
deux parties d'affilée
et qui se trouvait du coup avec quatre
et demi sur 108 donc avec un demi point
de plus que la moyenne donc voilà après
on a carvana Levan on a Prague et on a
ding qui décevant dans ce tournoi qui
joue pas très très bien des parties des
fois des gâchis dans beaucoup de parties
qui peut gagner qui gagnent pas des
parties perdantes qu'il arrive à sauver
notamment dans la partie contre Kemer où
il était vraiment à la rue
on a aussi du coup rapport 3 et demi
donc on va dire par has parce que à
chaque fois je le prononce avec
prononciation différente alors qu'il est
pas bien quoi il est pas bien voilà
et c'est le numéro 10
on a aussi du coup irrégasi one forest
qui est hier on fait une partie
spectaculaire que j'ai trop kiffé
hier qui arrive sa première partie
avant-hier du coup contre parrain du
coup avec Kemer qui du coup les deux se
partagent la dernière place donc donc
voilà on va voir un petit peu nos
caméras les parties qui vont commencer
du tout normalement dans deux trois
minutes vous savez qu'on a un petit
décalage au niveau des
au niveau de de des parties pour les
apparements de la ronde et ben du coup
on a quand même des chocs assez
intéressants on a du coup parrain qui
joue contre saut avec les Blancs
donc ça bon ben c'est pas forcément
apparemment que nous excite beaucoup
parce que bon bah par ami il est
vraiment vers la fin du tableau contre
ceux qui est dans les dans les
poursuivants si tu veux de d'abdu mais
bon paramalais blanc bon
pied c'est peut-être pas l'affiche la
plus sexy et après bon parram tu vois il
joue jamais trop pour faire nul ouais
donc si ça s'anime ou quoi tu vois s'il
se trouve le point ça le ramène près de
la tête bon sur un du coin de l'oeil on
va dire en tout cas ce qui est cool
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de parties en
fait où ça fight
et du coup ça c'est cool c'est assez
animé on a caressent contre Google donc
caractériel j'ai écouté son interview
après un batucarbona qui disait que bon
enfin ok il a un point et demi de retard
sur sur Abdou mais il a quand même un
parcours où les jours pas mal de joueurs
sur qui il pourrait en tout cas prendre
l'ascendant donc par rapport par exemple
45 là
il lui reste à jouer il lui restait à
jouer gokash aujourd'hui demain c'est
pas rame après ça sera chaud et après ce
sera Prague et réghasé donc bon il y a
moyen qu'un de faire pas mal de monde
après bon il va sûrement pas tous les
battre mais ça dépend aussi comment les
gens jouent parce qu'en fait genre
rapporte qui lui donne deux pièces car
on a fait une gaffe là il lui casse
baisser les cadeaux c'est même pas lui
qui a monté le niveau de jeu quoi ouais
mais c'est vrai que par rapport à la
confiance ben même si il a gagné deux
parties il y a un petit peu on va dire
par chatte
[Musique]
la confiance est revenue et peut-être
que maintenant du coup il va il va se
rappliquer réimpliquer et du coup finir
le tournoi sur une bonne note quoi voilà
aujourd'hui clairement il va jouer pour
le gain contre là c'est clair on est du
tournoi mais évidemment il y a rien de
fait peut-être même Google je suis déjà
fait du bien en fin de partie d'avoir la
petite journée de repos pour repartir un
peu un peu plus frais donc on verra mais
bon on est sur Carlson favoris
du coup rapport donc ça bon ben c'est
deux artistes
complètement deux artistes donc bon ça
on s'attend à une belle partie avec pas
mal de pièces en prises en tout cas
et donc on a appris à rognan Forest donc
à rien qui aime très solide avec les
Blancs qui va il va je pour le gain ça
c'est évident mais mais voilà ça se joue
pas trop pour faire le tournoi voilà
c'est ça
ensuite
avec les Blancs qui peut être très
dangereux qui est mort qui fait pas un
bon tournoi qui est pas trop en forme
qui est actuellement dernier du
classement donc contre le premier contre
Abdou qui est lui hyper en forme mais
bon après ça veut rien dire attends est
tellement fort que gamer porte
clairement la coller à Abdou donc en
tout cas on va voir un peu ce qui se
passe dans cette partie
et ensuite on a du coup Ding qui fait
pas un super tournoi contre Guiri Guiri
qui est plutôt en forme d'ailleurs dans
ce temps là
il faut avoir un ni point de plus parce
qu'il était très bien contre airghisy à
quelques rondes et puis il était pas
conclure mais globalement il joue pas
mal et digne bon en fait je veux dire et
je vous presque plus en fait donc c'est
important je pense qu'il joue ce tournoi
plus peut-être pour une reprise et pour
se mettre en forme pour le Championnat
du Monde que pour le tournoi en lui-même
en fait donc ça veut la porter un peu de
un peu de pratique c'est important et
puis après tu vois là je suis pas sûr
qu'il joue tellement ses préparations ça
sera un peu con de montrer ta prépa
trois mois d'un championnat du monde
bien sûr après il a 20 annoncé qui
jouait 4 avec les Blancs il fait des
trucs qui fait pas d'habitude
mais
donc
je pense Ding il joue plus pour se
mettre en forme c'est plus un endroit de
reprise que un tournoi il a une ambition
clair et net dans ce temps-là donc il a
balancé quand même Ding lors d'une
interview qu'il jouait les mêmes
ouvertures que d'habitude et qui se
prennent pas trop la tête après c'est
peut-être un bluff ouais non mais bon
je suis pas sûr c'est un bon choix
stratégique si il te sort des nouveaux
télés ici non non après je pense pas
qu'il sortira la grosse nouveauté pour
le coup mais c'est quand même du gâchis
mais ok on va voir donc donc là bon vous
avez sous les yeux la partie du coup de
Kemer contre Abdou donc c'est c'est une
Anglaise
assez assez standard
donc donc juste tranquille pour
l'instant
en fait c'était le même début que de
Carlsen contre Abdou et Carlson avait
joué E3 le G3 ouais c'est vrai
donc du coup on va te calmer pouvait
s'attendre à ce que Abdou répète
l'anglais symétrique mais donc je sais
pas sur G3 ce qui joue d'habitude Abdou
si c'est nouveau qui joue ça ou si je
veux déjà ça avant faudra-t-il qu'il a
joué aussi donc qui poursuit pas la
symétrie que G6 qui pourtant un coup
jouable
E6 bah pour probablement préparer des
cinq
donc je te mets attends
je suis en train de me faire les les
petites caméras là
de manière de jouer mais bon j'ai 6 pour
voir ce que oups plus pour sortir le fou
sur sa diagonale bah pas du fion de kéto
mais la grande diagonale mais également
pour contrôler le centre et mettre un
pion en dessin donc ce qui pourrait plus
ou moins transposer dans une tache une
ouverture d'arrache mais avec des
variantes bien spécifiques ou tu enlèves
des choix au blanc quoi
c'est un truc un peu à la mode alors je
sais pas s'il va jouer ça mais genre fou
G2 D5 c'est des quatre et
bouffe bouffe
il faut ses cinq
en fait
ça c'était pas trop enfin ça fait
quelques années maintenant que sont mis
à jouer ça mais c'était pas trop
considéré comme bon mais en fait la
jouer assez souvent et elle est
réhabiliter la ligne donc après je sais
plus exactement comment ça se passe mais
en tout cas si je jouable pour les noirs
avec un jeu dynamique dont la tension
isolée mais bon tu vois la colonne tu as
des H5 H4 ils peuvent partir
si le cahier des cartes bougent un monde
t'aime bien pousser le pion de D5 en D4
pas reste une cible mais avancée donc
voilà j'imagine c'est l'idée de jouer ça
mais bon on va voir pour le coup ok pour
l'instant pour l'instant on est bon
c'est la partie ah ok alors CD pour dire
je sais pas s'il va faire
mais c'était l'approche moderne de
double c'est prank qui a des profs c'est
5 et donc faut le 7 c'est l'ancienne
manière de jouer ou genre je sais pas
disons rock avec les Blancs rock noir
tout G5 ou tu mets un peu la pression
sur le cavalier F6 et du coup son dessin
et souvent les Noirs en fait fermer avec
C4 je me lasse prise avec éventuellement
et cavaler vient blanc vient souvent E5
et puis je sais pas toutes les bouffer
en C6 tu reprends du pion
ouais ça c'est l'ancienne grande ligne
bon je suis pas expert mais je sais que
ça se passe à peu près comme ça quoi OK
ça marche donc oui donc ça c'est
intéressant ce que tu as dit par rapport
au pion isolé parce que on a eu pas mal
de parties par un blocage comparant par
exemple avec un pion isolé et on disait
souvent que quand on joue contre un pion
les années généralement les blancs
doivent essayer de jouer pour l'échange
des pièces pour le contrôle de la case
du coup des 4 qui est la casque devant
le pion isolé et que du coup les noirs
doivent absolument jouer hyper dynamique
pour pour voilà pour jouer avec son plan
isolé quoi si jamais je joue pas si fait
que je change les pièces ben ce pion à
l'ongle mais il va être faible il va
tomber quoi donc du coup des fois on
peut volontairement jouer des pollutions
avec pions isolées
et mais bon du coup après il faut savoir
que monnaie il y a beaucoup de pollution
notamment dans la lapine où on joue où
on joue avec un pion isolé mais du coup
on joue de manière assez agressif assez
active donc en fait c'est un défaut de
structure à long terme si on enlève les
pièces
donc
faut pas s'enliser là-dedans après ça
apporte d'autres avantages notamment en
termes d'espace et d'activités de pièces
donc c'est dis donc on mise sur le
dynamisme de la position plus que sur le
long terme mais bah oui enfin si ça se
passe bien ça se passe bien quoi
en fait globalement enfin c'est dur de
dire plus que ce que tu as dit c'est
très bien le résumé ça va beaucoup
dépendre de la version de la position de
où sont placés les pièces c'est ça
c'est ça donc ça c'est surtout pour le
chat n'hésitez pas si pour quand vous
avez un pion isolé vraiment essayer de
jouer pour le contrôle de la case
Descartes et changer les pièces au
maximum
et puis et puis voilà et pour ceux qui
jouent avec un pion isolé ou qui est en
moins mal encombreusement ou même en
ayant fait exprès n'hésitez pas aussi à
jouer actif en tout cas c'est important
de bouger un peu les
choses quoi
ok alors juste rester à défendre
l'option il y a rien faire d'autre ouais
non voilà si on joue juste il y a une
partie qui est très connue d'ailleurs ce
que c'est mais une partie qui au moment
dans tous les bouquins ou tu sais que je
fous aussi ce qui avait le 7 enfin tu
défends juste le pion passivement en
fait elle a la longue bah les blancs
vont se déplier c'est plutôt à toi le
problème mais si vous juste vous
défendez votre faiblesse vous allez
avoir toute la partie alors que si vous
créez des choses pour même la partie de
Google contreparable Barbara mais il a
réussi à jouer des cartes il a réussi à
jouer actif et puis voilà quoi donc il
faut vraiment essayer de jouer actif
quoi quand on a c'est vraiment important
ok alors Ding diri on a du coup cette
position donc je reviens depuis le début
donc plutôt un récit pour l'instant
avec petit rock donc C4
petit rock B3
[Musique]
en gros on n'a pas envie de rebouger le
caillot 5 ce serait débile et F4 je
trouve ça bizarre donc
a priori oui et puis on prend des et
puis on prend des torrents ça a l'air
logique à moins qu'il est vraiment une
idée avec S4 quoi mais normalement ça a
l'air bizarre
donc du coup l'idée ça peut très bien
être F4 donc mais voilà après bon même
l'autre je veux dire faire ed c'est des
torins ouais ça serait pas débile parce
que globalement ce qu'il faut savoir
dans la structure de Benoni c'est que
bah là c'est des blancs mais c'est que
donc le joueur qui a la structure
mélodie eh mais changer au moins une
pièce légère parce que on a un port
manque d'espace et on a trop de pièces
pour l'ombre de cases disponibles donc
en fait un camion E5 qui va s'échanger
contre le cavalier qui est en C6 ou en
D7 ça aurait du sens avec le prend des
C3d donc ça avait l'air plausible après
là ce qui fait bah en fait le truc
bizarre c'est que guérir a bien
connaitre enfin
en tout cas
après c'est pas très étonnant aussi
guéri ni les ouvertures il est il est
bien préparé dans cet endroit mais
mais d'être préparé sur un machin comme
ça bah oui enfin c'est normal il fait
son boulot il est pro et en plus il est
connu pour justement
et donc là avec les Blancs peut-être
faire 4
en fait j'ai pas du tout envie de me
prendre le cadre de la peur des noirs et
me faire bloquer quatre
après je sais pas tu vois si c'est
vraiment déjà une menace des Noirs le 4
c'est peut-être le 4 qui est F2 on a
encore à cette pression sur le pion mais
bon c'est un truc latin en fait qui est
un peu relou
bon en tout cas c'est une partie assez
marrante parce que c'est une partie qui
sort un petit peu des des
on va dire des ouvertures un peu normal
quoi tu vois c'est c'est un peu nouveau
quoi mais mon guéri il se fait
surprendre dans l'ouverture et c'est lui
qui a plus de temps la pendule donc
c'est c'est assez marrant comme
ok bon bah on pourra revenir ça va être
une partie
de jouer
après éventuellement elle va faire aussi
eux prendre peut-être comme coup il a
fait qu'il y avait les trois je crois
avec les jouets
donc ok bon ça a du sens tu vas bien le
centre donc à un moment donné tu vas
faire peut-être manger 5 manger des
cartes
ça a du sens
on va voir
alors
blanc contre sourd
depuis le début si vous voulez
donc du coup il y a eu
OK
cavalier F3 petit rock à trois fois
[Musique]
l'idée en fait de ces cinq bloquer le
pion C4 et à la longue peut-être venir
peut-être l'attaquer donc ils disent des
fois à 6 des fois du cavalier à 5
et rend l'idée c'est de jouer contre le
C4
c'est la faiblesse blanche
en échange évidemment on a quand même
donné la paire de fou
et pas vraiment prises parce que du coup
tu allais faire tripler
voilà complètement
on risque d'en prendre deux et puis en
prendre trois donc en fait les pions ils
sont quand même
protégeants entre eux même si ce pion
est un peu faible il faut pas manger
quoi et le pion il est jamais vraiment
gratuit quoi il y a toujours des
problèmes voilà
donc il attaque C3
ok ok
j'imagine ce cavalier 2 ça défend ces
quatre mais ça perd des cartes du coup
bientôt aussi
[Rires]
et voilà et il faut voir quand même que
derrière tout ça il y a le casse moi
aussi qui s'ouvre par exemple dame je
sais pas trop géant racisme peut-être
et puis on prend alors pas mal tout
reprend un peu moins parce que je vais
mettre qu'on peut peut-être fermer la
colonne mais après puis on prend ben on
a accès en fait avec 15 noirs qui
peuvent être sympa sur le long terme et
un problème de développement tu vois je
peux pas poser le pion des ni le pion B
parce qu'en plus il y a aussi la le case
blanche et niveau
stratégique c'est pas facile pour la
marque
c'est pas anodin enfin c'est pas voilà
c'est logique mais bon quand même les
Noirs plus c'est j'imagine qu'ici bah il
pourra se dire allez je prends encore à
trois ou je fais quand même dessin
j'en sais rien moi prise en passant dame
prend des cadres de me prendre un on
joue la finale ok il y a la paire de fou
machin mais j'ai mon pion de plus donc
je m'accroche et j'ai quand même mes
arguments donc c'est ouais c'est du jeu
à trois résultats quoi j'ai envie de
dire
et ce qui est cool parce que du coup
so bah il va le son jeu solide et puis
s'il peut contrer ben il va y aller quoi
et par Ham c'est un genre de mec qui
aime bien jouer donc bah d'ailleurs on
l'a vu contre Google et c'est un petit
peu en voyant l'air
donc du coup sur le long terme il veut
quand même casser la structure là on
voit que c'est pas possible à cause du
vis-à-vis donc on peut imaginer un dame
prend ou un caballer prendre dans tous
les cas
la structure va se
détendu voilà car elle prend des cartes
ça te triste de perdre en ligne
d'ailleurs avec un Français 3 j'ai un
peu tout en or c'est un peu trop donc
mais du coup la lame soit Irak en fait
je pense qu'il va ok il se laisse tout
bouffer et puis
ça l'air bizarre d'en prendre des cartes
qui va être ici tu perds peut-être pas
tu recules
en Détroit je dirais mieux
et ta structure qui est quand même assez
mauvaise mais après peut-être on aura du
4 à 5 assez rapide quand on a un truc
comme ça il faut quand même le dynamique
donc bon
3 c'était à 4 x 3 si tu as tourbé un
tourbé 5 je sais pas enfin on va gigoter
lequel il peut lui rendre des 4 B5
et bon peut-être pas avec les blancs
mais c'est toujours un peu ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure de fou
tu perds un des deux pions C enfin
le remettre en C4 on mettra peut-être le
four en B2 et bon il y aura toujours un
petit truc long terme quoi
exactement qu'est-ce que ça vaut je sais
pas trop vous dire
mais ça va pas l'air absurde en tout cas
avec les blancs de jouer ça
ok il est censé connaître c'est lui qui
rentre là-dedans siamand donc les blancs
il doit sûrement choisir un peu
peut-être qu'il a plusieurs semaines
petit rock et pas non plus stupide parce
que on a quand même l'avantage de
développement et puis le pion C3 il sera
récupéré plus tard donc la tête qui se
soit il réfléchit à vraiment à prendre
décision dans la pollution soit juste se
rappeler un peu de ces lignes
[Musique]
puis des fois même ça fait pas de mal en
fait de juste réfléchir un peu plutôt
que juste débiter sa prépa et de
commencer à jouer c'est un moment en
fait on va vraiment sortir ils ont beau
savoir très très loin ce qui se passe
ils vont pas connaître ce qu'au dernier
coup et donc en fait si tu as joué tout
tempo tout tempo tout tempo et tu
arrives au 20e coup et tu dois te mettre
à jouer ton premier coup de la partie à
vrai dire si t'es pas chaud très souvent
c'est les mecs font des conneries à ce
moment-là
on va essayer de notre truc on sait
qu'on est censé être mieux tu arrives là
puis je sais pas faut enfin réfléchir
mais ça fait déjà une démarche la partie
a commencé et puis je sais pas tu es pas
chaud quoi
tu vois tellement en fait loin dans la
dans la dans la théorie et que ton
anniversaire il connaît pas et dès que
tu sors de la théorie et ben tu
continues à jouer vite parce que tu as
joué ta prépa assez vite d'écouter pas
rentrer dans la partie quoi donc en
termes de concentration c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant ce que tu dis mais là
bon bah ok enfin je lui dis pas de
réfléchir une demi-heure s'il connait
mais au moins regarder un peu
ça c'est un petit peu la fiche
une des affiches on a aussi Abdou qui
est en tête qu'on peut voir mais alors
du coup cette partie donc là il y a un
fou on a trois
dessins avec du coup fu B4 prise prise
fulf 4
moi je connais pas du tout mais
bon moi j'ai eu regardé une époque avec
Mathieu
c'est une époque qui date de plus de 10
ans et je dis plus rien et je dis pas ce
qu'on avait déjà regardé ça ou pas pour
le coup
ok j'imagine qu'il fallait en C2 j'ai
peur qu'un jour je prenne 5 et que j'ai
pas d'autres cases en plus juste
logiquement
ces deux mais ok ça pas trop de sens ça
bloque aussi la dame
et donc
tourbé un don de tourner
généralement on aime bien jouer avec ces
cinq en fait avec les noirs pour essayer
de jouer actif en fait après je sais pas
du tout si ça va être l'idée le problème
de ces cinq c'est qu'il y a genre Damas
4 qui nous a inventé
par contre je sais 5 un jour volontiers
ce sera dans l'idéal parce que je
pensais aussi à cavaler B6 en fait pour
bon pour juste bloquer contre aussi la
pousser ces quatre
et
je sais pas si c'est possible un jour
d'essayer de jouer sur la case carte
vous aussi mais je pense
j'ai envie de dire oui je sais pas mais
ça a l'air possible que soit un bon plan
puisque à BBC
dans le sens où
maintenant le foot sortir il y a plus de
ma carte aussi et puis du coup ça
prépare aussi ces cinq éventuellement et
donc jouer un peu sur ouais c'est un
coup qui a fait
position généralement
éventuellement maintenant c'est 5 et
jouable il y a plus de damakas pour
aller le prendre alors bon c'est ça qui
est fait 3 enfin c'est pas encore
complètement fait mais bon
c'est cinq on peut le préparer quoi
après globalement oui je veux sur les
cases blanches ça c'est logique pour les
Noirs enfin rien que vu la structure
puisque les blancs
donc c'est 4 c'est un peu le trou entre
les pions et donc si les blancs il va
jouer C4 ils ont une majorité au centre
ils font E4 peut-être aussi ça peut être
une idée mais là je pensais trop tôt
pas trop bien développé
et du coup là bon quand même avec les
Noirs faut dire que premièrement il faut
F5 on serait pas à mécontent de le jouer
gagner encore un temps sur cette tour
par exemple si je fais E3 qui a l'air
d'un coup assez naturel il faut F5
peut-être pour B3 et qui va revenir en
des six et puis on peut tout attendre un
échange
en6 de tout G3 aussi qui est intéressant
dans sa position pour ouvrir la
colonnage éventuellement mais du coup je
sais pas si tu dois manger ou pas
mais
je sais pas et d'ailleurs si vous prenez
6 si ça se trouve ça m'a l'air bizarre
mais c'est prendre si ça se trouve c'est
un coup je ferais pas en fait c'est
prendre
c'est pas la même pause mais
normalement on aime bien faire ça sonne
aussi on aime bien tu vois ça c'est plus
compact c'est plus cool
c'est clair que ça fait c'est très moche
mais après si tu arrives à bloquer la
case C4 c'est justement intéressant
parce que l'idée sur le long terme ça
peut être en fait de d'empêcher le jeu
des blancs quoi ça t'arrive empêcher
dedans en vrai c'est intéressant mais
sinon c'est caca là
je pense que meilleur objectif mais
ouais en plus là qui arrive direct en
fait donc du coup ton petit plan a pas
l'air terrible tu vois
donc oui non dame prend a priori alors
les caméras je comptais vous les mettre
juste après le petit tour parce que là
on va on fait un petit tour vraiment en
pince 3 minutes par partie après je
mettrai des caméras sur les joueurs ce
sera un peu un peu mieux
ok bon on va l'ouverture en tout cas ça
va pour le bocage a priori mais ça joue
enfin tout peut arriver
juste bon une petite faiblesse pour le
goûtage quand même dans son répertoire
c'est qu'il est facilement visable sur
des quatre enfin c'est ragozy dragon
il a déjà perdu contre Fabi
donc
c'était assez clean quoi il le vise là
dessus
qui nous avait dit qu'il avait joué
contre Google plusieurs fois et que à
chaque fois il arrive à tomber bien dans
la dans la prépa quoi donc
c'est vrai que bon c'est un super joueur
mais il a un peu privisible et à 2725 kg
là c'est
progression
pour se dire ok je dois travailler ça
pour continuer à progresser
et là bon bah lui ça a l'air d'être
clairement la faiblesse identifiée je
vais dire
préparé avec moi mais bon
il y a encore un énorme gap
là il faut il faut être prêt quoi il
faut vraiment avoir un niveau de
préparation quand on imagine même pas en
fait à quel point il faut travailler
c'est à la rigueur si tu es moins prêt
au moins que tu étais plusieurs
ouvertures à changer tu vois comme
airgaliser j'ai envie de dire
en fait on sait pas trop ce qu'il joue
ça a pas l'air top à chaque fois genre
les H6 ou je sais pas quoi mais bon tu
le joues une fois et les mecs peuvent
pas trop prévoir donc s'ils ont pas
révisé depuis un bon moment que savent
plus trop bah tu as une partie quoi
c'est ça en fait il y a tellement de
choses tu vois parce que il y a beaucoup
de joueurs qui jouent un peu de tout et
du coup ben
adversaire a plus ou moins se préparer
sur un peu de tout quoi alors que quand
tu veux toujours pareil mais qu'en plus
tu as un problème sur ton ouverture ben
ça c'est facile à viser donc donc voilà
bon en tout cas on va voir en tout cas
ce que gardienne peut nous faire dans la
partie
qui a perdu hier contre contre rapport
hier à ses créatif avec son petit H4 qui
passe tu as vu la partie
tu vois et tu dis bon bah écoute et tu
lui dis ah intéressant ton idée etc et
du bof pas l'idée je l'ai trouvé sur le
chéquier je sais plus quoi faire il faut
être intéressant et
bon moi je pensais que c'était un truc
qu'il avait peut-être quand c'est
italien
tu as quand même tendance
à vie et du coup H4 il a priori trouvé
sur l'échiquier
un peu dans le chéquier et il a besoin
de faire des trucs comme ça pour pour
s'amuser et jouer tu vois c'est quand
même en fait où il peut jouer une
pietroff un peu insipide et changer les
dames et c'est sûrement le truc
intelligent à faire quand tu as une
rencontre Carlson en fait de pas aller
chercher les noisettes mais lui il a
besoin de mettre ce feu sur les
chéquiers tout le temps et de jouer des
trucs créatifs ouais [ __ ] l'impression
en plus que la pétrole c'était comme si
il voulait pas chercher les noises mais
d'un côté il voulait parce que tu vois
il a jamais changé d'arme par exemple et
il a toujours
oui mais il est
il voulait mais pas tu vas rester comme
si il voulait l'attaquer à moitié quoi
c'est assez bizarre mais ok après je
pense que beaucoup de gens aussi ont
souvent un problème psychologique quand
elle parce que je pense que que rapport
par exemple on va peut-être pas
forcément faire la même partie
contrairement aux gens que Kartel
lui-même tu vois parce que en fait je
sais pas il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
sentent juste finalement
je me souviens au candidat j'arrive les
blancs qu'on époque et ça se voit que
les pots connaît tout
en fait juste avant tu peux faire
perpète ou un truc chelou bon il est
dans le truc chelou il a perdu avec les
blancs mais
ouais enfin sans jamais aucune chance
quoi et c'était complètement des
raisonnable mais ça peut lui arriver en
fait
d'y aller un peu la fleur au fusil et il
aime bien enfin il aime bien
elle fait plaisir je dépression créative
quoi bon en fait aux échecs si tu veux
si tu fais si tu veux bien bien échec il
faut s'amuser quoi et du coup bah lui il
a besoin d'avoir ses positions où il
s'amuse et oui il crée des choses et du
coup c'est clair que c'est c'est on a
toujours quoi et donc et c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on aime le voir jouer aussi
parce que du coup il est toujours
intéressant à voir parce qu'il y a
toujours des idées un peu un peu
marrantes quoi ouais c'est un mec c'est
un garçon dans un tournoi parce que
chaque partie joue quand en général
chaque partie il va faire des choses
pas bien
ah oui oui mais des fois hier c'était
c'était vraiment sympa ce qu'il a fait
hier
quelques années mais pas si longtemps il
y a trois quatre cinq ans je sais pas il
a gagné avec les Noirs ont une figurine
à rognon par exemple
mais bon évidemment c'est pas l'approche
pragmatique enfin c'est l'inverse d'un
seau que j'ai envie de dire
d'ailleurs en parlant de l'approche
pragmatique qui est
Prague
son approche contre Prague justement
derrière c'est sympa ce qu'il a fait
avec son son tour Eiffel même quand même
donner le pion G2
F8 la partie hier enfin moi qui suis un
genre d'attaque je trouvais ça
fantastique
sont en train de jouer là je peux te
dire plus ou moins oui parce qu'en fait
karwana quand il a battu bouqueth
c'était exactement cette position et
Google j'avais joué qui va aller E7 ici
publicitaire
sur Blitz stream on avait vu qu'en fait
dessus c'était jouable enfin même si
c'est rare d'habitude c'est toujours 8
ans le coup ici là
pour se dire comme ça sur à trois je
pars mettre
et de deux depuis 8 la tour elle peut
aider à la poussée au 5 qui libère la
position des Noirs donc bon c'est le
coup que j'étais connu bon je sais pas
le joue plus trop les Noirs en ce moment
et donc il a fait enfin ça va revenir en
même que la position donc le Carona a eu
contre contre B6 ou des deux caillot 7
ok admettons à 3 mais en fait vous cache
avait bouffé en cette fois ouais il a
bouffé ici et puis après il avait joué
je sais pas pourquoi il a fait x 6 c'est
très vite en plus à la pendule mais à 5
par contre jouable
ok je suis pas spécialiste mais à 5
justement c'est encore une autre partie
de Google
l'été dernier ou Google savait les
blancs contre 12 à Thomas
avait été bien et puis il a fini par
perdre sa fin c'était un peu le tournoi
aux Olympiades en fait bah à 5 pas con
tu as envie de faire à 4 fixer les
blancs donc ça force un peu à faire B3
pour pas se faire se faire fixer et du
coup tu peux faire fois 6 d'autant plus
facilement après pour
pas pour pour développer ce fou un peu
taper C4 et qu'il soit pas en l'air et
en plus comme tu as toujours A4 avec les
noirs qui est une menace latente souvent
les blancs vont réagir par B3 et A4 pour
plus en entendre parler et du coup tu
reviennes le contrôle la case B4 et le
caillot 7 il peut toujours revenir vers
C6 B4 donc ça avait l'air je vois pour
les Noirs ce truc là
c'était à ça
mais très souvent en fait l'idée c'est
que en fait on sent l'analyser avec
Kevin Kevin Tarrieux et qui on avait
commenté le tournoi et c'est vrai que
c'était d'un côté logique de faire ce
qu'il fait avec les Noirs parce que ben
tu as besoin d'ouvrir le centre et de
faire quelque chose mais d'un autre côté
tu viens de donner le foot 15 mois le
foot 15h dans cette position qui est pas
terrible enfin qui est bloqué derrière
un pion et qui fait pas grand chose mais
après c'est ça que le fou qui va se
réveiller en fait et du coup donc voir
vraiment comment tu tu vas jouer contre
ce fou enfin tu vois c'est c'est logique
et pas logique en fait à chaque fois il
y a un avantage inconvénient et c'est
vrai que là ouvrir la barre de fout des
blancs c'était pas forcément idéal là il
y avait eu 31 pour des coups préparés
sur la poussée et ben écoute c'est
maintenant qu'il sera déjà en face de la
dame et puis il le fou qui va s'ouvrir
aussi et après c'est 5 voilà c'était
doulou c'était un peu la catastrophe
prise
ça a été très très dur
il avait dit que de loin il pensait
qu'il était gagnant après kg
[Rires]
non je me suis mis excuse-moi je me suis
mis
je m'étais mis des glaçons dans mon
verre
et c'est vrai que j'avais vu qu'il y
avait que sur mon glaçon il y avait un
truc bizarre je dis waouh je m'en fous
ça va être un téléphone qui glaçon qui
est venu sur l'autre en bref
et en buvant je me suis rendu compte que
c'était un morceau de de d'oignon je
pense
qui était mission mon glaçon et du coup
je viens de voir une grosse gorgée d'eau
à l'oignon et c'est absolument
dégueulasse
c'est dégueulasse j'ai failli mourir en
direct
et il y avait un truc mais je savais pas
du coup
[Musique]
j'ai fermé la porte parce que j'ai tombé
mon fond vert il me cassait tout mon
chat
ok
on a pensé enfin avant de il a pas joué
il a fait dame G5 ça devait juste finir
la partie parce que tu m'as son principe
quand même quoi mais en fait pas tant
que ça parce que H6 je crois
ça je prends des 5
fous ranger 5 et puis fait F6 quand avec
les noix dégage ton fou il pousse 5 et
il trouve du contre je
bon je sais pas à quel point mais oui en
fait enfin je peux comprendre tu es mal
développé avec les blancs ils vont
enlever sa dame il y a peut-être faire
des Séville faire pression sur ces
quatre machin et
bref mais oui après madame B2 tu es mal
mais là oui on rejoint le truc on
faisait avant sur la prépa de Google
c'est qu'en fait il rentre tout seul
dans cette vente comme un grand enfin
c'est son ouverture c'est lui qui
faisait parfois assis sur C8 et en fait
si tu fais C5 et que tu actives te
foutais trois tu auras une idée très
concrète derrière la tête donc l'avant
trouvé concrète mais si Dame B2 juste ça
refuse
ouais il y a un problème dans la préparé
clairement je sais pas qui l'a confondu
ou ce qu'il a pas regardé ou non
je sais pas
aujourd'hui donc il nous fait fouder si
il change pas le fou lui il sera 3
et
bon du coup la position elle a plus trop
une tête de ragozine c'est plus une
sorte de semis là j'ai envie de dire
un peu bizarre
tu peux imaginer
en fait ce qu'il y a de bizarre en gros
on a l'impression c'est que le cahier a
mis deux tempo 7 au lieu d'avoir fait un
tempo pour 17 le fou il a mis deux coups
pour aller en D6 au lieu d'un coup on
est passé par des quatre mais en
contrepartie on a fixé le chou blanc des
deux
non il pourrait être mis en B2 peut-être
éventuellement j'en sais rien mais c'est
peut-être un une des idées et bon on a
forcé un peu les blancs à jouer une
expansion à trois B4 qu'ils auraient
peut-être pas fait sinon on aurait
peut-être fait des trois petits rats
quoi c'est les deux autres tempo à jouer
s'il y avait le choix et que peut-être
au contraire qu'un coup comme à 5 pour
les Noirs maintenant
ou un C5 qui fait tout péter enfin pour
le coup alors là je suis sûr que lui il
a une approche très concrète il a 1h43
donc
il sait ce qu'il fait et
Prague il a un petit peu moins ouais on
voit qu'il a une heure 12
il est pas forcément dans la position
qui
le qu'il connaît quoi enfin niveau
préparation il s'est fait surprendre
quoi peut-être qu'il faut des si c'est
enfin je sais pas c'est une nouveauté
mais pas loin en tout cas OK
ça marche bon intéressant en tout cas de
voir car voilà qui joue qui joue la
position des deux couleurs et voir un
peu du coup ce qu'il a prévu là dessus
alors si on poursuit notre petit tour
avec Aronian vent de Forest donc ça
c'est une mélange je pense je vois de
donc voilà avec ces 6 qui avait 6 E3
donc ça c'est pour le coup par contre
j'ai jamais trop vu c'est plutôt
A6 qui a du coup
c'est vrai que le fou normalement il va
plutôt garder 6
il joue que des trucs surprenants
donc il est bien préparé mais ça pas
toujours d'explication très rationnelle
ce qu'il fait parce que c'est juste ordi
à fond quoi tu as vu la partie contre
qui était qui était assez marrantes la
foule aussi c'est le 5 là sur la ça ça
serait dégueulasse aussi ça
c'était surprenant au niveau de
l'ordinateur mais après on avait du mal
à comprendre nous en tant qu'humain
pendant les concessions qui faisaient en
fait
d'avoir bien préparé que l'ordi à un
moment tu vas jouer tout seul
et il perd parce que bah il y a le fou
noir qui s'est retrouvé en E5 et enfin
des trucs normaux en fait il a fait un
G4 avec les Noirs qu'il a fermé la
position et qu'il fallait pas le faire
en fait il y a pas bien compris la
position et dans c'était compliqué quoi
mais je veux dire c'est pas
ça va être un ordi là j'aurais bien mais
à un moment nous on va jouer en tant
qu'homme et vu que la position elle est
plutôt
fondamentalement mauvaise
sur le long terme faut trop jouer de bon
coup tout le long de la partie pour pour
la rendre jouable quoi
et forcément donc on est humain un
moment on va être un peu plus faillibles
et faire un truc un peu moins précis et
du coup enfin je pense que c'est pas
trop une bonne idée de jouer vraiment
des trucs comme ça trop mauvais
positionnel non mais juste que l'ordi te
dit que ça va parce que
ouais enfin à moins de tout connaître
par coeur parce que dernier coup de la
partie en fait tu vas avoir un problème
quoi et il a eu enfin c'est juste normal
en fait là c'est pas de sa faute mais je
pense c'est une mauvaise approche là
pour cette partie là je suis d'accord
d'accord donc c'est vraiment parce
qu'hier hier j'avais des cours et puis
en fin de mes cours j'ai parlé de cette
position enfin pas cette position exacte
mais un peu le même genre tu vois de me
rendre toujours avec A6 c'est 5 ou
toujours avec B4 c'est 5 pour ouvrir en
fait ton main et une partie que j'avais
joué c'était la ma première victoire
contre un grand maître
en partie officielle et c'était ça que
les Noirs laser
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de mettre là-bas mais pas
de laisser derrière les pions toute la
partie si il est vraiment moche là-bas
mais dès qu'il est assez simple
évidemment il rejoue alors c'est 5 c'est
un coup où on perd B5 donc il faut
préparer donc soit défendre ce pion par
A6 Avant et du coup bah on a plus aucun
problème à faire c'est 5
comme ça
peut être jouable ou pas mais en fait
faut arriver à faire jouer enfin que
l'un ou l'autre marche non c'est mauvais
signe d'ailleurs il y avait une partie
là c'est pas ça va te parler mais une
partie que j'ai vu c'est une partie au
tata style
il y a peut-être 10 ans
alors on Inde oui bravo
et
à rognan il a perdu en 15 coups avec les
Blancs il y avait eu un C5 alors que je
crois qu'il y avait un pion il y avait
un pion blanc
et il y avait eu un C5 et le pion est en
prise 2 fois enfin tous les temps en
prise en fait c'était notre préparation
etc et après après l'analyse il avait
dit rien qu'il fallait qu'il bosse
prépare-toi voilà
et du coup bah d'ailleurs j'avais parié
j'avais perdu un pari
au Festival des Jeux contre bah tu
connais Romu j'avais vu il y avait il y
avait un bouquin avec comme couverture
ben la position où il y a ces cinq qui
arrivent et je lui dis ah tiens mais
c'est la partie de Ryan Inde et il me
dit non non
non c'est une partie de je crois de Vlad
mais qui ressemblait il y avait juste un
H6 un truc comme ça je sais plus ce que
c'était mais et du coup bah j'ai perdu
mon meilleur quoi
comme d'hab tu sais que je porte mes
Paris mais là c'était vraiment pas de
chance quoi et
[Musique]
mais dans l'idée voilà c'était ça quoi
et
mais du coup il y avait une partie voilà
qui est des fois on peut jouer ces cinq
même si on ne fait que les pions parce
que l'activité est trop forte bref donc
après bon une préparation c'est autre
chose mais sinon si vous n'êtes pas
préparé comme léanland juste essayer de
jouer simple et de sortir vos pièces
je suis une bonne ouverture c'est une
bonne ouverture ouais c'est une bonne
ouverture
5 va arriver ok
enfin l'autre partie en fait qui fait
un rognon à Nantes
c'est une vieille partie de robinstein
c'était content
c'était pas un errant parce qu'en fait
je crois que les dents a fait ses 5 en
un coup mais c'était le genre de
position
avec les deux fous braqués et ça avec
des cloches quand le royaume H1
des trucs comme ça
mais oui
se mettent à attaquer de l'autre côté ça
fait mal ça peut faire mal
il y avait une petite question dans le
chat c'est quoi les ventes
c'est juste que le candidam c'est on va
dire tout ce qui découle de décades des
5c4 et donc le Meyran c'est une des
possibilités sur le candidat mais mais
voilà
c'est ça
une des possibilités dans le grand
comme la les autres parties dont on
parlait avant là les ragozymes c'est une
autre possibilité sur le candidat et
peut y avoir des Slaves il peut y avoir
des
tonnes de trucs
et rapport donc on voit on a parlé tout
à l'heure de de la créativité de rapport
qui vient de mettre notamment H4 pardon
[Musique]
bon je suis pas expert du truc je sais
pas trop quoi dire
en gros bon non mais on fait un truc en
résumé rapido les blancs
ils vont pas trop de défauts de
structure enfin ils ont tous leurs pions
attaque juste les Noirs en fait vise les
cases blanches
puisqu'ils sur cette grande diagonale la
dame H4 aide à contrôler ou 4 et puis
mal cavalier c'est une autre pièce
blanche notamment s'il vient en dct6 par
exemple disons et les blancs bah le fou
B2 peut pas participer à cette lutte
donc en fait ça va être un peu qui va
mettre en place est-ce que les Blancs
travailler à faire un coup comme dessin
qu'à un moment fermer le fou B7 ouvrir
le fou B2 jouer les cases noires pour le
coup sera un peu pris au dépourvu entre
guillemets ou les marges justement vous
figez tout ça venir 4 ok peut-être faire
F5 pour supporter le le le caméléon 4
etc donc ça va être une lutte un peu
comme ça et donc les blancs avec la
paire de tout intérêt ouais bon soit des
cinq je sais pas mais soit sinon aussi
faire C5 pour tout faire péter là-bas
des choses comme ça mais pour l'instant
le développement il est pas si simple
pour les gens vu que le foie fin bah il
doit défendre G2 c'est ça et puis on
sait pas trop mettre le roi encore bon
pour l'instant il y a évidemment l'air
en fait donc
à voir après est-ce que les blancs
peuvent quand même sortir jusqu'à
blanche laisser [ __ ] ranger deux faire
tourger un du Grand rock tu files un
pion ou deux et puis tu as un gros gros
sens de développement
tu vois je sais pas enfin bon
avoir
est-ce que ça va prendre
mais est-ce que c'est un carré est-ce
que des dessins qui arrivent parce que
on va dire le combat de fond quoi
ces deux joueurs de toute façon c'est le
joueur qui me surprendre un peu dans les
ouvertures donc on s'attendait
un combat de ce type là et on va voir un
peu ce qui va se passer alors j'ai vu un
truc marrant dans la partie Ding si tu
veux on peut aller voir ça
parce que c'est une position hyper
créative je vais vous sortir des caméras
maintenant peut-être un petit G4
ouais alors
je sais absolument pas quoi dire mais
ça va être très concret quoi bon
j'imagine il veut faire le prendre des
quatre
alors on s'est arrêté où on s'est arrêté
du coup
en fait
et j'ai 4 donc là clairement c'est
peut-être pas forcément l'idée de la
prépa vu que là bon on voit le coup il
est orange chez nous et puis mais bon
dans l'idée tu vois c'est clair que que
Ding avait
il avait des idées tu vois mais c'est
peut-être pas forcément le bon coup ici
G4 mais bon les Gets enfin G5 chasser le
cavalier ramener maintenant la dame à
l'attaque ouais
un peu tout et essayer de ramener les
pièces en jeu quoi tout cas c'est le
sens
attaquer comme ça
un peu homme des cavernes mais on y va
quoi
en tout cas c'est intéressant parce que
tu vois vraiment que Ben le centre c'est
généralement quand tu fais une expansion
comme ça avec les pions devant ton roi
de manière générale le centre est
toujours fermé tu vois pendant les
Indiennes l'exemple typique quelqu'un ou
les pions sont fermés et puis une fois
que le centre est fermé et ben je vais
balancer je balançais j'ai 5 G4 H5 alors
que là il y a une grosse tension
ensemble et je balance j'écartes donc ça
par contre c'est généralement un peu
moins
facile quoi moi conseiller aussi mais du
coup
bon c'est hyper intéressant que là il y
a eu le point F4
j'imagine mais je sais pas en fait non
non mais je sais pas du tout en fait
c'est en fait je sais pas si on fait e.f
enfin je sais pas maintenant plus tard
le fou B2 qui est la 3 ils m'ont l'air
horrible quoi
juste du truc visuel mais en fait je
sais pas ce qu'on a fait avec les Blancs
là dans l'ouverture
ça a l'air de
et
du coup j'imagine c'est une autre idée
alors je sais pas si c'est de faire eux
prendre si c'est de faire G5
intermédiaire si c'est de faire quand il
prend F4 et je sais pas quoi garder une
tension mais si c'est pour faire le
point F je sens que normalement c'est
pas bon quoi tu sens que les pièces sont
trop mauvaises en fait voilà le centre
est fixé et tu auras jamais même ce
cavalier il pourra jamais revenir en vie
quoi tu vois quand même mon fragile ok
mais on a l'impression qu'il est et puis
bah et après quoi donc ça peut pas être
bref à mon avis enfin c'est pas possible
que je vais voir ça donc soyez vous pour
reprendre mais bon
pour
comme ça quoi enfin pour faire tourner
pour faire pour faire des coups j'en
sais rien peut-être hein
bon d'après la barre d'évaluation ça a
l'air pourri mais
à vue d'oeil c'est un coup je regarderai
du sens tu vois pour mettre le cavalier
là tout ça
[Musique]
mais oui du coup quand ils regardaient
mais sinon ça peut être jusqu'à ici deux
peut-être aussi on enlève ce cavalier
qui était emprise après faut prendre des
quatre et on se connaît je vais le
centre mais c'est mais en fait enfin
parce que les Noirs à tout le monde
aussi il peut faire un coup comme F3 il
devient ce pion et de récupération
mais bon vu qu'on a un peu plus d'espace
la balle aura plus de pièces peut-être
qu'on craint pas grand chose mais ouais
c'est une position rare enfin oui je
pense ça jamais eu mais je veux dire
même le type de position est rare
donc est-ce que c'est le prendre l'idée
est-ce que c'est qui quatre au lieu de
je sais pas
et bref 4 il peut aussi un jour avec gs5
venir en dessin pour le cavalier vous
avez parlé aussi tout à l'heure de jouer
G5 aussi intermédiaire qui fait aussi
éventuellement
au moment
possible quoi alors après le cavalier ou
se dire ok je te le fil je joue pour
bouffer des pions genre f-3
puis on prend F6
prend H2 qui prend F6 ça fait déjà pas
mal l'option quoi ça fait des pions si
ça va ou pas enfin du radis mais
peut-être enfin
bon je pense qu'on prend le 3 mais bon
donc en fait oui
[Musique]
il y a plein de possibilités c'est hyper
compliqué
mais tu vois comme si je joins [ __ ] quoi
que j'ai pas le temps de d'investiguer
comme un fou la position le truc qui
doit pas être très rassurant pour Ding
c'est que guéri a quand même 1h36 a
répondu ouais et c'est pourtant lui qui
s'est plutôt fait surprendre à la base
donc c'est assez incroyable franchement
[Musique]
jusqu'à fou des 6 il a fait fouger 3 il
a pas pris en 6
donc bon on peut remettre un peu les
coups d'avant voilà et c'est développé
l'attaquer la tour qui bouge qui attaque
le fou qui rentre chez lui les Blancs
n'ont pas échangé genre que leur fous et
on en est là
bah après ça a pas trop mal pour Google
hein
est-ce qu'on peut commencer à imaginer
un C5
[Rires]
parce qu'on voulait le faire tout à
l'heure c'était une idée donc c'est ça
que des fois ça peut être même vite
faire ces quatre aussi pour pour je
contrôle ton C3 et aussi contre le fou
aux deux je sais pas si c'est une bonne
idée
ça peut être une idée pourquoi pas je
sais pas
parce que l'idée comme des dessins que
c'est qu'après la prise bon il y a un
pion isolé en
dessin mais il est pas forcément
atteignable pour l'instant il y a aussi
un pion vous avez dans cette roi qui est
plus faible que le mien je pense
mais moi j'aime bien c'est 5 mais je
sais pas du tout
si c'est un coup possible viables dans
la position ça peut permettre
je sais pas si c'est le meilleur ou pas
mais c'est oui
après j'ai du mal à trouver d'autres
candidats en fait que faire des coups on
sait pas trop cuisiner
cette parce que du coup
développement et voilà ça doit pas
manger de pain comme coup
à 5 peut-être pour dire je te fais un 4
giga j'ai encore ta tour je prends de
l'espace ça peut clairement se regarder
enfin parce que on peut même aller
jusqu'à à 3 après tu vois tu fixes à
deux les blancs du coup mais en finale
fera toujours qu'il fasse gaffe à [ __ ]
bien faut prendre à deux tu as la tour
avis tu peux passer par A4 enfin ça peut
donner des idées c'est un peu lent mais
bon ça peut se regarder mais en soi
peut-être c'est 5 ça c'est naturel enfin
ça peut être le plus naturel de le tout
quoi
en plus on évite tous les trois avec ces
cinq puisque on peut échanger faire une
fourchette
donc
ça peut se regarder après donc souvent
c'est 5
à l'idée ça va être soit faire ces
quatre soit c'est prendre un jour mais
plutôt c'est 4 je dirais ouais
oui c'est 4 c'est un peu comme dans
les blancs ils vont essayer de jouer
pour 4 jours
et comme il y a plus le fond des trois
le cahier de Jean F3 il est pas en D2
donc il perd du temps
peut-être que c'est envisageable et puis
bon dans un monde idéal avec les noirs
on essaie de faire ces quatre Dame des 7
cavalier A4 et B5 à 5b4 on joue vraiment
sur l'expansion parce qu'on m'a quand
même on aura trois contre deux donc
là contre C3 et à deux donc pousser les
pions en tout cas ça c'est un des plans
qui qui est plausible dans ces dans ces
positions après il y a pas mal de
possibilités aussi je pense les blancs
peut-être limite il faut faire dépenser
faut pas se laisser peut-être fixer
comme un ok prise et qui ait des quatre
ou pas mais pourquoi pas
et puis bah fout des trois et puis on va
vite troquer quand même parce que il va
pas rester là toute sa vie
et je veux dire c'est équilibré mais
les blancs font pas des Français
fait planter ces quatre je pense qu'on
est un peu enfin on est plus qu'un peu
en retard
[Musique]
si ça se passe tout noir un peu
qui est intéressant parce qu'en fait
c'est final là sont au final assez sympa
pour les noirs avec ce pion c'est trois
qui font toujours
prendre donc
ce qui va prendre est-ce que c'est une
vraie histoire
mais bon je pense pas que enfin c'est
même pas c'est je pense les gens sont
vraiment pas moins bien
pourquoi pas enfin il peut peut-être
faire d'autres coups aussi mais il y a
pas de raison de enfin ouais franchement
Google s'en sort très bien dans
l'ouverture aujourd'hui et il y a une
position très convenable
j'imagine
il y a peut-être d'autres moyens de
défendre B7 et puis qui est C4
c'est un côté risqué alors après faut
avoir parce que tu peux laisser fou
prendre puis on prend et tu as une
mauvaise structure après évidemment si
tu plantes ton fond d'écran avec les
Noirs tu seras content donc ça va
dépendre de ça mais aussi qui est C4 il
va peut-être simplement te l'enlever en
revenant en D2 avec son cavalier une
fois que les pièces sont échangées sera
facile à faire pour les blancs alors
qu'ici c'est vrai que pour l'instant bah
C4 c'est dur à faire quoi donc avaler il
est bien en fait on a pas envie de
bouger ce cavaler en fait on veut juste
empêcher ces quatre donc en grand
cavalier C4 tu risques de faciliter les
choses au blanc
donc c'est pas c'est pas un bon coup je
pense mais par contre tour C8 c'est 5
oui là tu restes dans la logique
le camion C4 si il est stable il sera
très bien mais si tu fais plein
d'efforts pour te faire échanger juste
en un coup des blancs c'est du temps un
peu gâché
en fait c'est le coup logique
je pense même que Carlson d'abord ça
c'est 5 et c'est juste le coup normal
depuis le début de la partie on voulait
juste à cinq mais après tactiquement
avec le four à 3 ça marchait jamais il y
avait toujours des problèmes
d'enfermement
du coup normal quoi
envisageable mais
c'est 5 c'est une idée très thématique
dans ce genre de position salut François
alors j'ai vu que tu m'as envoyé des
messages mais j'ai pas regardé encore
[Rires]
et ça n'a pas loupé
qu'est-ce qu'on ferait pas sans toi
alors du coup
ok est-ce que une autre partie
intéressante qu'on pourrait suivre
[Musique]
un test dans le tournoi
bon malheureusement je connais pas trop
bien la position
[Musique]
ça va pas l'air mal pour les noirs
ok donc là c'est un peu le même genre il
y a eu un C4 et du coup maintenant on a
un trois contre deux un peu comme tout à
l'heure et du coup même une idée avec
plus tard à 6 B5 serait une idée qui est
possible tu as des fois du A6 B5 et on
joue pour P4 en fait c'est possible
mais voilà et
Clément est-ce qu'on fait quand même fou
d'être pas je suis pas sûr mais bon
peut-être ça se regarde et sinon
cavalier E4 c'est sûrement aussi une
autre possibilité à côté noir alors s'il
faut prendre le 7
je pense parce que le problème c'est que
si on prend de la dame on montre il y a
Caval de prendre des seins qui est
chiant donc elle va les prendre et bien
sûr
le coup forcé si on est là ou alors
qu'elle va les prendre cette croix mais
il faut calculer les complications
chacun a ses pièces en prises
à regarder tu vois mais j'ai tendance à
bien aimer les noirs de manière générale
dans sa pollution parce que j'aime bien
mon trois Condens en fait mais ça c'est
moi j'ai un blocage là dessus
j'aime bien moi en trois contre deux à
l'époque j'avais travaillé la ragousine
avec les noirs et j'étais fan de trois
contre deux et finalement c'est une
ouverture qui m'a pas trop réussi donc
je garde vite mais
ça donne un objectif long terme mais le
plan est clair
non mais là en plus je pense mieux parce
que en fait le
problème de ce truc c'est que les blancs
ils ont la même majorité de l'autre côté
ici ça peut être dangereux le roi mais
déjà quand il y a plus les dames
s'enlève vachement potentiel
genre
une partie qui illustre un peu cette
lutte entre les deux qui étaient gagnées
par les Blancs c'était Bobigny
Capablanca
avreau 38 je crois et c'est une
demi-heure à partir de bosny il faut
être très fier de sa partie mais c'est
vrai enfin c'était une partie où en fait
chacun fait son plan hyper hyper logique
quoi les Noirs ils ont fermé que C4 ils
ont lancé les pions sont attaqué les
pions la dame peut-être gagner un pion
il y a pas longtemps les blogs 4 5 ils
ont attaqué la loi et la taxe droit
a prévalu on va dire mais
donc ça monte s'il peut se passer mais
clairement il suffit d'un tempo de plus
ou moins et tout d'un coup ça marche
très bien pour les Noirs donc ça donne
des parties intéressantes où chacun a
son plan et ses objectifs et là
j'imagine c'est bien pour les noirs
il a quand même une demi-heure de moins
à la pendule et
il s'est fait surprendre quelque part je
pense parce que c'est pas normal de
d'être d'avoir perdu une demi-heure même
40 minutes c'était 1h40 au début au bout
du coup avec les Blancs ça c'est assez
étonnant
il s'est bien entouré quoi il a
quasiment comme secondaire
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas donc un
ancien champion du monde feed
donc 15 secondes
il a des bonnes idées il
est bien quoi donc ouais Abdoul lui il
fait l'effort pour ses ouvertures soient
nickel quoi ouais mais tu vois qu'il est
que qu'il est très très sérieux tu vois
enfin même dans sa je trouve que même
son attitude sur la checker tu vois il
dégage un truc de de sérieux quoi tu
vois
en fait au début ouais je sais pas trop
ce que ces ouvertures je veux dire tu
vois tu es plus ou moins talent quand
même mais il pouvait avoir un peu des
poubelles et il savait s'en démerder
mais
t'es pas méga propre quoi et puis là
plus ça avance plus bah il a gardé
toutes ses qualités de savoir bien
calculer d'être débrouillards d'être
créatif ou quoi mais en plus avec le
côté maintenant plus solide plus voilà
les ouvertures qui tiennent vraiment
bien la route et il a plus tellement ses
poubelles donc en fait c'est quand même
toujours plus facile de jouer quand tu
es bien comme aux échecs et du coup il
joue toujours aussi bien avec des bonnes
positions maintenant
on nous demande ce que l'entraîne plus
alors je sais pas disons ce call of je
sais pas s'il a déjà entraîné
personnellement tu es juste le capitaine
de l'équipe d'Ouzbékistan
pendant les Olympiades tu vois comme par
exemple nous en France c'est Mazet mais
ça veut dire que que Seb c'est
l'entraîneur de mvl ou excellent trainer
de tout le monde quoi c'est juste que
pendant la période de 15 jours cette
capitale et donc bah tu peux discuter
avec les joueurs tu peux peut-être
donner deux trois idées partager des
trucs travailler pour eux
voilà après si ça se trouve ils ont
quand même bossé ensemble sauf que là
j'étais pas au courant mais si c'est ça
dont tu faisais référence
ça veut rien dire en fait d'être Captain
de Olympiades vis-à-vis de ton travail à
l'année
et le quel truc là c'est
Ivan le joueur d'origine Hugo et qui
hollandais maintenant mais qui vit qui
vit je sais pas où il vit mais il a
longtemps été aux Émirats ou par la
banque en tout cas et qui fait une belle
carrière d'entraîneur après avoir été un
très beau joueur quoi il a atteint 2700
il y a plus ou moins 20 ans de ça quoi
[Musique]
ils avaient pas mal de de beaux tournois
quoi
ils ont envie de faire cavaliers aux
quatre
pose la question
malgré tout
d'abord
il faut
des vitres
je vais filer des cinq cages je vais
prendre 5 est-ce que
ça se doit aller là
probablement plutôt que les Francs ce
serait dame prend en dessin
ce que toi quand même
ok
enfin j'en sais rien j'ai l'impression
que peut-être les notes a du jeu enfin
tu files d'être un pion mais tu
développes tout tu fais des pions
faibles à droite à gauche on attend que
tant que le roi blanc est pas en
sécurité tu peux te permettre en fait de
faire ce genre de choses parce que
parce que les Blancs ont vraiment
doivent rocker rapidement quoi donc tu
peux faire des menaces un petit peu
avant et c'est tout un peu la pagaille
donc je sais pas enfin tu vois ça c'est
juste bon je vois que la jauge elle est
pas complètement d'accord avec
je sais pas exactement pourquoi mais bon
peut-être que ça va en fait c'est juste
la chose qui va passer je sais pas parce
que juste par exemple un coup je fais
logique bouger la dame on sait pas trop
donc là il y a plusieurs
mais juste pour montrer en fait l'idée
bon là il y a même une tour de deux
enfin ça l'air chaud en vrai c'est ça
puis même si je fais pas 15 blessés je
te fais dame 3 5
ouais puis même même dans l'idée tu vois
sur un truc comme ça
du Fou des trois ouais mais en fait je
vois pas du tout
ça après ce que je prendrai plus tard
mais d'abord je pense que
en plus le rock c'est quand même une
idée intéressante pour garder le roi en
fait sur une mauvaise case
[Musique]
en gros sur ce qu'on voit j'ai envie de
dire
ça peut l'air trop mal pour ado enfin
c'est plus au blanc de toutes les
problèmes je sais pas c'est un mot
problème mais à solutionner ce qui est
en train de se passer parce que
j'ai du mal à comprendre la courbe
parce que j'ai l'impression que toutes
les cases ont l'air compliqué cette dame
B4 et il te dit bon bah écoute j'attaque
là donc j'ai le temps de OK
mais bon mais oui
au pire je prends juste 5
on doit probable ah tu perds
prise C3 et que peut-être tu as le temps
ok tu mets ta cassette tu m'attaques B7
[Musique]
j'entends très bien ok mais en tout cas
on voit que en pratique c'est pas simple
il y a des sujets à prendre il y a
beaucoup de gens qui peuvent arriver
mais bon
[Musique]
mais normalement ça marchera jamais je
monte juste c'est trop intermédiaire là
pour l'instant c'est ça ouais bon l'idée
c'est que si je prends là en fait et
bien je peux pas laisser 4 mais du coup
j'ai du caballer prendre intermédiaire
et du coup une fois qu'il prend là je
prends la donc ça gagne mais dans l'idée
le cavalier 5 peut-être qu'on peut le
faire pour l'instant maintenant là avant
que le cavalier puisse avoir cette case
la vaisselle pour de retrait le truc en
fait parfois les Noirs s'il y avait un
cavalier 5 et qui en C6 tu peux le
laisser changer 6 pour prendre de B
parce que ça te renforce des 5 ça ouvre
la colonne B bon bah B2
je sais pas en fait les Noirs enfin
c'est loin d'être clair qu'il faille
faire que c'était juste le truc je
voulais regarder un peu parce que une
approche directe et si ça marche ça
marche bien
mais ok il y a d'autres d'autres coups
ici c'est pas peut-être c'est sûr on
peut
on peut envisager à d'autres manières de
tenir la position j'en sais rien
peut-être même parce que H6 c'est un
coup en fait
provoque pour un FX pour faire un F6 si
on perd des 5 on se venge sur 5 il faut
bouge j'imagine juste en enferme
encore parce que sur un G5 j'ai toujours
cavaler 5 mais bon peut-être que
peut-être qu'en fait on y va peut-être
en fait je vais te manger le fou quand
même ouais non je refais ça on crois
qu'il est 17 ou je sais pas quoi et en
fait au final ton fou il va être un
petit peu
G4 enfin ça rentre tout de suite
j'en sais rien non mais toi tu peux
partir donc je sais pas en fait
bon en tout cas ça mène à des positions
qui sont qui sont assez assez
intéressantes très créative
et
tu as même mettre dans l'attitude tu as
de
d'Abdou tu vois il est vraiment hyper
concentré hyper motivé il a plus un en
tournoi c'est pas le genre de joueur qui
va se relâcher et perdre du coup a
priori
donc
je pense que c'est devenu vraiment un
joueur hyper costaud dans ce format qui
va qui va d'ailleurs monter très très
vite en vélo là il est à +25 points et
l'eau dans le tournoi
c'est monstrueux
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il a pas joué notre ami
F50
comme prévu pas comme tu as proposé de
pièces mais bon c'était pas obligé
c'était juste pour regarder il a
et maintenant bah il faut savoir il faut
regarder est-ce que tu veux manger ici
est-ce que tu veux manger de là est-ce
que tu veux manger là
et là c'est compliqué donc tout à
l'heure on me disait que eux prend F4
c'était pas forcément une bonne idée à
cause de du coup du cavalier à 3 et du
Fou B2 qui est enfermé dans la structure
et qui en aura beaucoup beaucoup de mal
à ressortir
franchement ça a l'air et même une prise
en décape moi j'ai du mal à j'aime pas
en fait je me sens
si j'ai l'impression qu'il y a trop de
problèmes sur la diagonale noire et que
les pièces sont placées de manière trop
marginale avec les Blancs je me sens pas
bien tu vois
je sais pas pourquoi
mais ouais c'est c'est un peu bizarre
plus de sens à mes yeux maintenant
que le cavalier est parti et ben j'ai la
case des cinq accessible pour mon cavale
donc pour moi
je peux même faire cavalier 5
intermédiaire mais ok bon cahier 5
c'était un petit peu plus un pari parce
qu'il faut prendre un H2 tu vois c'est
chaud non mais je reprends juste
un jour faut prendre un H2 je peux même
le lâcher des fois juste pour pour
[Musique]
c'est bon on arrive à faire péter tout
ce centre blanc
et bon on a que le cahier à 3 un peu
bizarre mais bon qui reviendrater d'eux
et on verra plus tard au pire mais il
fera un truc
du coup peut-être que prise là c'est pas
terrible peut-être au niveau du coup
pas encore de le prendre en décape mais
parce que j'ai regardé mais je me lasse
cavalier 5 puis peut-être même derrière
manger là
j'ai l'impression que maintenant les
cases les pièces blanches arrivent assez
vite parce que tu vois tu as la colonne
F qui est ouverte tu as la dame qui peut
très vite partir en H5 tu as le fou qui
est déjà à moitié sur G7 tu as le Caval
en dessin qui va faire mal tu as le fou
qui peut venir en 4 tu as une tour
blanche en qui peut arriver là
il y en a plus qui font n'importe quoi
en fait
ils sont tous au bois et du coup
mais c'est pas trop enfin ça va
à suivre
alors la patron garder ce qui se passait
tiens on va goûter 5
en fait toutes les parties sont assez
sympas assez animées
rapports
si vous voulez on peut on peut aller
voir ce qui se passe je vais vous mettre
la caméra qui correspond à ça
spécialement vu venir mais alors
probablement l'idée je suis pas sûr de
moi c'est de faire G4 et qui est pas F3
et toujours pareil dans cette conquête
des cases blanches
on s'arrête et où
c'était trop noir
encore le même fou c'est
pour bloquer le flou peut-être que du
coup il a voulu faire passer le fou à
l'extérieur pour faire ça je sais pas du
tout bon après non ça part très malin
quand même d'ouvrir la colonne enfin
d'ouvrir le gaz noir ici peut-être que
c'est pas l'idée
comme Google voilà
c'est peut-être pas la l'idée du siècle
mais du coup faut 4
comment on pourrait comment on pourrait
justifier ce coup parce que ok le fou il
fait la même chose que ce sont baisser
ou à 4 et 3 c'est pas une idée parce
qu'il y a toujours des gens là non mais
bon peut-être qu'il pleut non
il veut pas avoir trop pièce blanche en
ces deux Détroit elle veut pas de dames
et de quoi mais je sais pas pourquoi pas
qu'il est 17 en fait
parce que peut-être que du coup tu veux
mettre le cavalan en C6 mais du coup bon
cela dit allez tiens une tentative
d'explication c'est que si vous voulez
vraiment faire G5 comme ce qu'il fait
des cinq ça va le faire chier il va
faire 5 a priori
et en fait il se dit ouais mon fou
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là-bas le fou il
est pourri le fou serait mieux 4 dans
cette position là bon au moins c'est
à part cette explication là j'ai du mal
à non mais c'est complètement parce que
là par rapport à son prochain coup qu'il
a ajouté quand même G5 comme tu disais
et ben des cinq qui clairement un coup
candidat parce que bon ça menace une
découverte sur la tour ben je ferai le 5
pour fermer la
et mon fou ben il est passé à
l'extérieur de la structure donc mon fou
il est pas débile derrière la structure
donc en fait c'est clairement ouais je
pense c'est ça et bien sûr les DJ 5
alors pourquoi on jugeait 5 comme tu
l'as bien fait tout à l'heure l'idée
c'est clairement de jouer en fait je
pense G4
pour en fait empêcher F3 parce que du
coup pour l'instant F3 c'est pas
possible parce qu'il y a un il y a un
clouage mais du coup peut-être une idée
ce serait de dire ok je suis un rock
après je fais F3
plus tard ton fou il est pourri j'ai la
barre de fou etc et puis au final bah
les blancs sont assez content
et l'idée c'est que du coup quand tu
rentres et ben du coup je fais G4 et je
suis libre
voilà F3 ne peut pas être joué parce que
je le mange deux fois et du coup bah tu
auras toujours un problème sur ton pion
jet d'eau tu pourras pas sortir le four
à cause du bureau et il faut trouver
quelque chose il faut trouver une idée
quoi
donc non mais intéressant tu vois encore
une fois que ça rapporte qui qui
est un genre très créatif quoi très
malin quoi j'aime beaucoup parce qu'il
joue il joue il joue vraiment son jeu à
lui tu vois vraiment comment il le pense
et il est moins axé tu vois enfin il
joue un peu mon classique que les autres
joueurs
et
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
faire des trucs excentriques par pour
faire un truc excentrique là
et puis bon ça marchera ça marchera pas
mais c'est pas
nous empêche pas de faire grand rock
un fou empêche le rock si il est sur le
passage du roi pas sur le passage de la
tour
oui
s'il peut faire rock c'est pas grave
du monde ainsi c'était quoi le match
par contre j'ai pas compte qui c'était
mais alors si c'est un match c'est
forcément qu'on ne garde pas
de carpov donc peut-être qu'on a les
deux mais en gros du coup il y avait eu
donc un des deux joueurs je sais plus
peut-être c'est du coup qui allait voir
l'arbitre avant
est-ce que je peux ok ici
c'est absurde quand même au championnat
du monde quoi le gagnant du match de
hier champion du monde et tu vas voir
l'arbitre si tu peux ok quoi
alors est-ce que la ravi d'ailleurs peut
te répondre à ça parce que c'est quand
même une indication
à chaque tournoi peut changer donc ok
moi je te dis il a 3 jours que je
continue une histoire ou ça a mis perdu
contre Salgado il avait une position ok
compliqué quoi je crois qu'il avait deux
tours pour la dame en finale bon c'était
un il a un peu pression mais ok bon ça
joue quoi et ça mix lève à 40e il va
prendre un café il revient il a perdu
autant parce qu'il pensait qu'il y avait
autant 40e en fait pas du tout
et
donc du coup demander à la cadence c'est
toujours voilà mais une règle de jeu
d'échec et quand des champions du monde
moi aussi tu peux ok c'est marrant donc
du coup là oui mais que il voulait être
bien sûr avant de roquet qu'on lui dise
bah tu as ton droit tiens
un peu con quoi
[Musique]
c'est clair que c'est mieux de demander
quitte à passer un peu pour un con au
niveau de l'arbitre plutôt que de
tromper clairement et là notre comité de
la partie aussi mais c'est vrai qu'à ce
niveau là en fait c'est juste surprenant
mais mais dans l'idée en fait voilà
c'est que si le fou était en F3
là je pourrais pas ok parce que je passe
par un échec vous voyez
par contre la tour quand je fais un roc
elle passe il y a un fou mais il a pas
Échec
donc du coup ça c'est possible
enfin juste j'ai regardé ce que les gens
disaient dans le chat donc en fait ouais
c'est pas un champion du monde mais en
fait ça a eu l'effet d'un chemin du
monde j'ai envie de dire parce que
c'était le match de 74 au final les
candidats et vu que Fisher c'est pas
ramené pour le match le vainqueur a été
champion du monde
et en fait c'est une position
ou
[Musique]
en fait il a une arme de plus
franchement
qui attaque la tour H1 et dans le bon tu
as plein de coups qui vont être très
bien pour les blancs il y a pas de
problème et donc j'imagine qu'elle est
bien voir l'arbitre pour être bien sûr
qu'elle a le droit de faire pirate qui
est que bon qui est pas un truc bizarre
je sais pas tu vois pour assurer le coup
parce que au cas où tu avais d'autres
coquillages mais safe tu mets ton rôle à
l'abri la tour est plus attaquer tata
dames de plus et d'ailleurs après petit
rock car parfois j'ai un coup quand je
chante un autre il lui abondant
donc je pense c'est vraiment pour
demander pour assurer le coup
non après c'est clair mais bon c'est
marrant quoi à ce niveau là en fait
juste c'est comme si Carlson là il joue
contre Goku
est-ce que je peux rocker ici quoi ça ça
nous surprendre nous on a beau enfin
m'avoir que lui ou même il y a même des
débutants qui pourraient même lui
répondre
tu vois c'est marrant quoi provocation
je pense pas non
non en fait juste les joueurs qui sont
stressés et tout ils veulent être sûr
ils ont un petit doute et en plus même
quand tu es en tournoi etc bon bah des
fois juste voilà quoi moi je me suis
j'avais une partie
bon c'est pas du tout pareil mais
à Saintes à Barcelone et j'avais joué un
grand maître cubain et donc un mec a
quasiment 2006 quoi et j'avais sacrifié
ma tour pour rentrer dans une finale
avec roi contre roi de cavalier et c'est
nul dans la théorie donc du coup bah ça
allait faire nul mais bon quand j'ai
fait ça bon lui même pas un regard ni
rien et puis je pour gagner quoi et du
coup j'ai vu c'est qu'avait ce rapporté
de moi je comprenais que j'ai un peu
flippé quand même
et ça fait peur les cavaliers justement
tu as pas beaucoup de cases mais dans la
théorie j'étais sûr que c'était nul mais
toi j'avais quand même 2300 hello déjà
et
donc je connaissais tu vois c'est pas ça
qui m'attend au hasard mais dans l'idée
quand il s'approchait de mon roi j'ai eu
peur de me formater et bon après voilà
et j'ai fait un truc que c'est pas bien
de faire et d'ailleurs je le fais jamais
je parle jamais
de nos parties en cours etc c'est pas
cool mais pendant que j'étais debout
j'ai demandé un pote si vraiment ça
faisait nul moi contre de cavaliers tu
vois alors que je le sais c'est sûr mais
en pratique si tu veux
j'ai douté quoi j'ai dit [ __ ] les
cavaliers ils vont mater quoi enfin et
en fait à chaque fois tu as toujours une
case donc il faut jamais
si tu fais exprès tu peux t'arrêter mais
si vraiment tu le fais exprès quoi ça
dans un coin il faut vraiment faire mat
aider mais normalement il y a pas de
maths tu vois mais du coup je me
comprenais pas j'ai eu peur j'ai eu un
moment de doute
parce que les cavaliers arrivés et aussi
j'aime vraiment
alors je connaissais la règle donc du
coup je comprends en fait tu vois ce que
tu ce que tu me dis par rapport
au fait de pouvoir rocker va pouvoir ok
tu vois et donc tu le sais mais tu as un
doute tu dis bon peut-être que tu vois
et au bout de la partie qu'il y a quand
même un stress il y a un enjeu et je
peux comprendre
imagine il m'a congrès de la fille il te
change là
merde
salut Hélène
[Musique]
on a quand même pas mal d'expérience et
je pense qu'au niveau anecdote on a
quand même pas mal de trucs mais
c'est marrant quoi
[Musique]
donc j'ai 5
positions alors pour que c'est un petit
peu bougé on peut aller voir Prague si
tu veux
caméra 3 je voulais caméra en même temps
donc du coup tout à l'heure on disait
que Fabi karena avait joué du coup la
position enfin la l'ouverture qu'il
avait utilisé lui-même avec les Blancs
contre gocash
donc food D6 on s'est arrêté à B4 C6 et
du coup on imaginait éventuellement ces
cinq jouets et voilà donc c'est ce qui a
été joué ce qu'il a fait donc il prend
l'espace et après B prend fou les Blancs
ont plus d'espace de ce côté là mais
clairement un des plans des des Noirs ça
va être de jouer en fait pour E5 pour
casser un peu le centre et évidemment un
cavaliste 5 voire quatre qui va arriver
et les blancs qui devraient jouer d'un
morceau sur la loi avec leurs pièces les
noirs sur la droite pendant que les
blancs vont plutôt avoir un jeu sur la
dame normalement
donc
elle est fou c'est ça
moins que mais même même en fait des
fois
c'est pas grave oui on s'en [ __ ]
ici non parce qu'en fait il y a toujours
de cavaliers 7 en fait et au final qui
va s'ouvrir donc par un plat ici
je regarde juste avant de dire des
bêtises et G4
aussi
si je défends avec un fousset 3 tours 8
et on va souvent réussir à récupérer
notre pion en fait en écoutant solide et
puis on a la paire de fou on a aussi du
Fou F5 qui peut arriver
sur la structure et le pion 3 qui
arriéré du coup et du coup le fait de
jouer un jour F6 bah ça va ouvrir la
position et on a quand même des toiles
casses blanches aussi de manière
générale il y a toujours un peu de jeu
donc il faut il faut il faut voir
peut-être que 5 peut-être que c'est un
peu c'est un proto peut-être
en fait
je sais pas si c'est une bonne idée
c'est quand même le bon foot et noir ici
peut-être pas en fait mais essayer de
jouer à 5
mais bon sur ce qu'on a vu il y a pas
vraiment de raison de pas le faire
clairement pas mal quoi
qui peut être intéressante donc la
caméra on a déjà vu il a pas joué encore
depuis faux F5
mais est-ce qu'on a pas le site qui est
défoncé en fait alors
c'est vrai que ça va un moment que
personne joue donc il y a un problème
ok
il est possible que en fait depuis tout
à l'heure on commente un peu dans le
moment du retard sur la transmission à
laquelle on est quatre coups plus tard
bon bah si ton PS mais alors ça on peut
rien y faire
[Musique]
de membres j'ai vu j'ai vu et que en
fait même il y a trop de membres en fait
il y a trop de membres
les joueurs
un peu la technique il me dit de seconde
[Musique]
j'ai préparé une petite
sauf que la caméra elle est pas du tout
prête je suis désolé je pensais qu'elle
était prête la caméra neuf non voilà
toute belle
en direct vous avez 45k en direct
du coup
et
le site il est down pour l'instant donc
dès que dès que ça revient
même si j'avais au moins les chéquier tu
vois et
on pourrait peut-être avec un autre site
de rattraper les coups quoi mais le
problème c'est que là j'ai même pas
accès
on veut juste faire une petite pause de
10 minutes le temps que ça revienne si
vous voulez on va faire une
tu sais pour avoir un écran bleu
ouais bah écoute je vous propose qu'on a
une petite pause ouais il me le site il
marche pas du tout chez moi pas j'en
reviens à 16h enfin je dis un truc au
hasard mais écoute dormir sur leurs
pieds quoi
dans tous les cas votre branche les
filles et puis on voit quoi
dans tous les cases avec Kevin on
faisait une pause à la préau deux heures
donc on va se faire une pause maintenant
et restez quand même parmi nous hein ne
partez pas
va revenir dès qu'il y aura une saura
rebrancher les câbles
donc d'ici quelques minutes dès qu'on
peut on revient voilà voilà on vous
laisse quand même je vais vous mettre
une vue quand même
je vais être sympa quand même je vais
vous mettre la la Food screen
je vous mets sur 45 je sais que un chat
genre qui aime bien 45 alors je vous
mets 45 Go cash
en grand écran et puis et puis dès qu'on
dès que ça revient de toute façon bah
d'ici 5-10 minutes on est là quoi
allez à tout de suite à tout de suite
et nous sommes de retour avec du coup un
nouvel échiquier
on a essayé plusieurs plusieurs
solutions mais absolument rien marche
donc vous avez la page officielle des GT
c'est le site officiel de retransmission
qui va nous servir aujourd'hui
d'analyses bon malheureusement il y a
pas de flèche possible il y a pas de ne
pas jouer de coupe mais au moins on
allait partir en direct donc
c'est le mieux qu'on puisse faire pour
l'instant et bien sûr on va faire
attention on va essayer de refresh comme
à chaque fois pour voir si on peut faire
marcher mais pour l'instant
ça ne marche pas du tout chez moi là
j'ai beau j'ai beau refresh la page
c'est tout tout noir et quand ça va être
tout noir
mais
[Rires]
[Musique]
écoute
et le cavalier 5 il y a eu quoi qui
aille prendre à me prendre ok
[Musique]
on four
il a protégé son petit pion en dessin
comme ça
et finalement il fait froid
bah du coup le plan des blancs bah j'ai
pas de flèche on va essayer de faire
mais du coup j'imagine que une rupture
en E4 ça peut être une possibilité même
si on a toujours un pur isolant des
cartes je sais pas si c'est possible de
faire de jeux pour un 4
en tout cas ce qui est clair c'est que
le point noir c'est va être B5 à 5 et
jouer avec la marge en réalité de
l'autre côté
donc
moi c'est que j'aime bien jouer pour les
pour les noirs bien général j'aime bien
c'est position alors bonne ou pas bonne
j'en sais rien mais c'est des gens que
moi perso je j'aime bien jouer tu vois
quand tu pousses tes petits pions comme
ça
est-ce que tu penses à un plan je pense
les noirs sont plutôt mieux
après bon ça peut être dramatique pour
les mains non plus mais c'est plutôt de
faire gaffe
tu peux trouver un moyen que les blancs
de tout liquider genre E4 puis on prend
on reprend disons un coup comme tour D8
tu vois j'ai un truc au hasard des
blancs font des seins tu bouges tout en
dessin qui te prend ses quatre et puis
il y a plus rien sur l'échiquier quoi ok
malheureusement je peux pas faire des
flèche mais imaginez bien le petit pions
trop qui monte en E4 pour s'échanger
contre le pion dessin qui après tout
reprend on aura un pion isolant des 4
mais l'idée c'est qu'un jour on peut
peut-être te pousser pour que la tour a
littéralement à 4
par exemple mais bon après prévoir mais
c'est des potions qui sont quand même
pas mal pour les pour les Noirs vous
voyez que le roi blanc qui aime plus
ouvert
mais en tout cas c'est les blancs qui
doivent
qui doivent trouver qui doivent trouver
quoi faire parce que sinon comme tu le
dis à la majorité de la dame pour les
noirs et le roi blanc un peu plus faible
il y a peut-être les Noirs Peugeot un
coup comme F5 à un moment pour juste
tout bloquer et se dire vas-y maintenant
tu fais plutôt 4 je vais partir sur V5 à
5 B4 crépion passé etc donc
je pense que tant que les gens dans
l'opportunité il faut bien réfléchir à
cette idée-là de 4 bon c'est le marche
je peux pas garantir mais en tout cas à
un moment donné il faudra que je
dynamique parce que si on se laisse
avoir avec le plan de noir qui est de
pousser le pion dessin jusqu'à A5 et
faire B4 si on fait rien de spécial avec
les Blancs on peut surtout un peu
submerger par la par la majorité noire
sur la colonne B
donc avant que là il y a eu H5 joué par
par canard donc H5 qui a un coup qui a
beaucoup de sens donc éventuellement une
idée d'un MG4 enfin j'ai 4 non mais de
H6 je pense en fait avec peut-être ta F3
dans 6 c'est de casser un petit peu du
coup
[Musique]
la structure sur le roi noir
c'est très possible
et
je te répondre
le leader ça boite
juste la partie peut-être pour gagner du
temps
donc on va tourner on va changer un peu
pendant ce temps là j'essaie de de
refresh mais ça a pas vraiment l'air de
vouloir marcher
ok alors du coup j'ai dingly Rennes
Guiri
et là c'est pas mal animé donc on s'est
arrêté
[Musique]
que c'était quand même l'idée de G5
et après cavalier F4 a eu prise qu'on
avait dit que c'était pas forcément
clair qu'il le fasse ça ouvrait le foot
15 noir en B2 qui amène une belle
diagonale
et du coup après fou le 5 qui est hyper
logique qui échange d'ailleurs ta bonne
pièce en B2 la dame
[Musique]
C21 c'est logique mais les Noirs c'est
quand même plus dur de trouver des coups
parce que les pièces marchent un peu
dessus et ils sont un peu moins actifs
tours 8 donc avaler B1 donc vraiment les
noirs qui qui tarde les dessins donc
un bruit
de quoi abri de pièces
sauf que j'avais
ouvert le challenger
à côté et que la Challenger a un coup
qui a joué qui a été joué par contre
quand je vais dans le master dans
l'ouvrir chez moi
mais en fait il marche tellement pas
qu'il y a même plus rien qui branche les
fils quoi ah oui d'accord
moi je l'ai en bleu parce que j'ai un
fond bleu mais c'est noir
je vais voir si je peux changer comme ça
mais je pense que non
je pense qu'on est complètement
[Musique]
bon c'est pas grave
je sais pas s'il va convertir encore
c'est bon je sais pas à quel point il
est beaucoup mieux parce que bon ok il y
a rien de faire mais quand même sympa à
5 qui veut un peu ouvrir il lui dit non
d'ailleurs ça va donner aussi une case
en B5 cette histoire très intéressant
pour les blancs et puis ce pion à 5 qui
peuvent me faiblesse plus tard
OK
[Musique]
pour chasser un peu le fou G4 une fois
que je fais H3 et ben je peux faire
peut-être faire Dame des deux l'autora
et un cas un problème sur la colonne des
quoi avec les avec les Noirs il y a ce
cavalier en E5 en D6 j'ai qu'avait les
B5 qui va arriver aussi
j'aime énormément la position de dingue
le sang qui n'est pas très stable enfin
il y a pas de méga découverte mais je
veux dire c'est pas arrivé donc
[Musique]
il peut être attaqué il est pas stable
et même si les pions blancs sont avancés
on voit bien que même les blancs en plus
d'espace donc du coup c'est pas grave
je crains un peu moins avec ton H3
peut-être que juste le fougères c'est
pas trop évident en fait c'est un outil
on bouffe 5 si vendait ça ton double
tour va rentrer et puis ça reste de
perdre du matériel bon pour rentrer en
C8 c'est un peu la queue entre les
jambes quoi
qui était le seul coup pour garder la
colonne à partir de 5 bah je manque un
peu de de
possibilités tu vois et là je crois
c'est un coup intéressant parce que le
foie enfin le fou G4 va te faire bouger
et en H5 j'ai mon cavalier en F4 qui va
manger s'en fout
et c'est vrai que
le fou va devoir rentrer à la maison
quoi donc c'est pas encore où mais
fougères c'est peut-être un coup d'épée
dans l'eau tu vois c'est si tu penses
gagner un temps en sortant le fou mais
au final tu vas te faire un chasser plus
tard donc à voir si vraiment c'est
possible
qu'elle va le prendre C4 ben ça prend
trois pions a priori
mais ouais je j'ai l'impression que en
fait si tu veux tu es seule pièce qui
sont
plus ou moins active au centre cette
cavalier quoi et du coup une fois que tu
fais ça tu as plus rien et je sais pas
si ça vaut le coup en fait de vraiment
parce que tu vas gagner quand même des
pions et une qualité c'est vrai mais la
case des 5 elle va être vraiment forte
pour moi tu as plein de faiblesses comme
le pire c'est 5 chez les noirs qui vont
toujours être là je suis pas sûr du tout
que
qu'on va réussir à faire quoi
un truc
enfin s'il y a double prise en C4 dame
B5 qui allait prendre ses cinq
intermédiaires
du coup en fait on va quand même avoir
une pièce de plus j'imagine à la fin
j'espère que vous arrivez à suivre
malgré tout désolé
c'est pas de notre volonté tout ça on
est un peu bloqué je
referai tout le temps ça exerce à la
vision ouais c'est ça et puis donc au
moins vous avez les positions et puis on
vous montre un peu les choses les
caméras marchent donc je pourrais même
vous mettre la caméra sur Ding tu vois
c'est vrai que j'y pense j'y pensais
plus mais je vais vous mettre un petit
un petit ding
ding guide quoi il est numéro 5 regarder
une petite caméra sur dingue
contre guéri
un petit peu pour le voir en entier
merveilleux
et
voilà après si vous avez des questions
que même que vous voulez poser des
questions à Fab
ou à moi-même mais bon j'imagine que
l'invité du jour c'est quand même plutôt
faible peut-être sur ce que vous voulez
[Musique]
ben là il y a pas grand chose à analyser
enfin c'est un peu dur sans bouger les
pièces mais en tout cas n'hésitez pas
qui est grand maître international
et qu'il a d'ailleurs
auteur de
de son livre sur la la
kalachnikovation
mais pourquoi pas un de ces quatre et
puis j'ai fait plutôt de vidéos
donc totalement avec avec Kevin
je crois que je crois que Walkyrie qui
qui serait intéressé peut-être pour
cette copine alors je sais pas si tu es
intéressé
a
on va aller voir ce qu'il fait
pas bien quoi
peu importe la position en fait il est
jamais bien
on va aller voir sur la caméra aussi il
est bien ou pas bien
et
[Musique]
du coup du coup on a du coup cette
partie donc parentale est blanc c'est ça
donc c'est le problème sur le pion C4
et ces trois
et puis la petite attaque mais j'ai du
mal à voir vraiment où ça va il y a
quand même pu en D7 qui peut être en
prise vous voyez que le rat noir il est
ouvert il y a pas de pion devant le roi
mais le roi il était bien caché quoi il
y a quand même une cabane de fête
H5 c'est pour empêcher comme G4 c'est
pas pour attaquer c'est juste pour
empêcher les coups comme G4 qui peuvent
faire un petit peu un peu difficile et
du coup tour C8 prend ces quatre qui va
être ici je pense une menace donc est-ce
qu'on joue cavaler des six avec les
Blancs est-ce qu'on joue cavalier deux
c'est pas
ça préfère les Noirs dans la position là
clairement moi aussi parce que tu as
l'impression que les problèmes des
blancs ils seront la vie quoi
tu vois en terme plus récurrents de
faiblesse et puis bon je sais pas le
casse blanche il peut être assez fort
s'il retombe sur la déménage en B7
mais peut-être des faiblesses là-bas
exploiter un jour donc j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a plus de potentiels pour les
Noirs alors en fait bon et peut-être
rien de fait et que sur un très bon jeu
ça fait un truc plus ou moins équilibré
mais
priori ça a l'air
et d'ailleurs C4 ce serait ce serait je
suis pas une blague je n'arrive pas à
faire
c'est les cartons
ouais ça pourrait être c'est quand tombe
attends attends on me demande de
rajouter les noms je vais vous rajouter
les noms en fait je vais pas faire à la
main mais je vais parce que
ouvrir un tout petit peu
c'est celle là du coup faire en direct
parce qu'on a l'occasion de me voir
jouer bah je joue plus trop en fait
alors je vais avoir quelques rondes
d'interclub dans les clubs étrangers le
prochain tournage fera Reykjavik
fin mars début avril
il y aura le top 7 je sais pas quoi Top
16 je crois que ça s'appelle
début juin et puis cet été je suis pas
sûr peut-être que je joue un truc ou pas
on verra mais en fait je joue plus trop
quoi
en Espagne
ouais ouais
je sais pas trop pourquoi
je me suis demandé ce que tu étais parti
faire là-bas
en fait c'est que moi j'étais avec Axel
quoi
en fait l'été dernier
l'été dernier qu'est-ce que on était aux
États-Unis en vacances et puis je sais
pas regarde un peu moins possible et
puis on dit ouais tiens enfin descend en
Espagne ça peut être cool bon en fait un
peu derrière bon allez vas-y on y va et
puis le truc arrive et puis plus
approche je me demande mais en fait
pourquoi mais bon en même temps c'est
inscrit les mecs nous ont réservé
l'hôtel enfin peut-être pas trop
possible leur dire ouais en fait non
quoi donc bah écoute on y va quoi mais
ouais de rendre par jour machin en fait
ça n'a aucun sens
pas trop amusant quoi enfin
j'ai plus l'âge quoi pour ça donc
grande idée d'aller jouer ça mais c'est
pas grave j'ai un peu joué j'ai pu en
Espagne manger du Ramon
ça va enfin le bon côté des choses
voilà donc non en étant je vais faire ce
sera plutôt des tournois dans des
endroits on va dire sympa ou que j'ai
envie de visiter donc genre l'Islande
j'aime bien donc ce sera l'occasion
c'était quoi ma dernière grosse peur je
pense que je la connais est-ce que je
peux je peux je peux répondre
vas-y alors je me trompe peut-être
mais je sais que tu avais fait une très
très grosse partie contre se fait
touchkine pour gagner le Cap d'Agde
et voilà là je vais la partie mais je me
souviens que j'avais été complètement
fan en 2013 ouais donc c'est à 10 ans
quand même mais en tout cas moi je me
souviens de celle-là que tu as battu un
roman un grand joueur ouais mais c'est
pas mal en fait
après peut-être que mon meilleur tournoi
de ma vie ça a été de battre faire ce
second à Cavic
c'était en 2015 je pense c'est ça date
déjà un peu mais c'était vraiment fort
en fait fin le tournoi il y avait un
Navara mais dire oh
je sais plus moi j'étais genre 40e mélo
au départ quoi et donc faire deuxième
execo c'était bien c'était l'ami qui
avait gagné la fin un énorme tournant
genre 9 et demi
j'ai fait second ex aequo avec elianov
mais en fait je sais pas ce que je
foutais là quoi parce qu'en fait il y a
que des mecs
je retourne 2007
pas trop vu en fait sur les premières
tables avant mais que tu vois petite
fille grande femme ancien 2016 et quand
même jeune c'est aussi en 2007 quoi
alors à l'époque à être un futur 2007
mais ok
c'est vrai que
26 je suis pas à 30 ou 50 ou 60 ou je
sais pas quoi en fait mais ouais
moi je suis fan parce que c'est un genre
qui est ultra positionnel et qui qui
place bien ses pièces et j'aime bien
j'aime beaucoup le style j'avais vu
qu'il avait il avait sorti non je crois
qu'il est pas sorti il a failli sortir
guéri à une coupe du monde
il est passé à quasiment
50 ans non
je sais plus 60 de 50 ouais par là enfin
c'était vraiment
et il joue d'échec
c'est un peu un boucher quoi il a bien
envoyé c'est un truc c'est un super
joueur et joue la laisse indienne entre
autres et
c'est un genre que j'aime beaucoup
regarder parce que c'est un genre qui
qui très offensif que je m'organise etc
et du coup ben grosse perf enfin just
gold c'est pas un joueur facile à battre
avec les Noirs j'ai fait une jolie
Française après
bon depuis c'est il s'est vengé il m'a
rebattu depuis qu'on a joué ensemble
mais mais voilà ça c'est un bon souvenir
alors je sais pas si c'est ma dernière
grosse paire enfin j'ai battu d'autres
joueurs entre temps on va dire mais sur
un tournant entier
ok probablement je referai jamais un
truc comme ça quoi de
finir cette grande attelle tournoi bon
surtout que maintenant je peux et je
joue mal quoi donc
quand tu joues moins tu joues d'office
toujours un peu moins bien parce que je
pense que la pratique c'est important
quand même
il y a la pratique bien sûr et puis il y
a aussi qu'en fait je travaille plus
quoi donc bon ouverture c'est moins ça
le le la pratique c'est moins ça enfin
tout est moins ça quoi donc la confiance
est moins ça c'est comme ça quoi
mais du coup oui je fais autre chose
c'est plus maintenant je donne plus des
cours un peu les vidéos un peu les DVD
un peu ouais bon c'est plus joueur quoi
je sais pas c'est compliqué
ce qui est chiant
quoi
[Musique]
comme si je pense que c'est bien la
personne que je pense
je pense que c'est ma tante du coup non
c'est pas une monnaie de faire ce que je
voulais faire
donc du coup on va faire G4
que sur H3 dame prend G4 il y a toujours
G3 qui va clouer la dame
donc les deux droites c'est une idée je
te dis bah écoute si tu fais G4 je
prends et je fais dans ma tête et puis
je te mate quoi
c'est un petit peu le coup qui te qui va
te dire de ne pas jouer G4 quoi après tu
en prends H3 il y a peut-être du
[Musique]
F5
j'arrive pas à briller les pièces mais
je suis sur d'un point F5
si je fais ici
enfin si je fais F5
qui arrive puis j'ai 5
profitant du clouage ou quoi c'est pas
pas facile pour les Noirs
prise bien sûr on peut pas reprendre à
cause de l'enfilade comme tu l'as dit
et sur un coup comme G6 G5 attention
bon ça se trouve il faut jouer un coup
comme des cinq la clé noir enfin j'en
sais rien tu vois c'est là c'est moche
parce que c'était vraiment pas ce qu'on
voulait faire que de base on veut gagner
ces quatre on veut pas dédoubler les
pions blancs mais si ce qui avait lieu
quatre est trop fort avec la Dame des 4
et G4 G5
[Musique]
peut-être que on doit le faire
pas de gaieté de coeur quoi enfin
c'était pas trop le t'es pas trop le
plan de base mais
des fois c'est comme ça
sinon
parler de grande base moi j'ai jamais
joué
et bon ça m'étonnerait que je le batte
si je compte le lit mais
non c'était pas moi le genre en question
mais malheureusement qui n'a pas recul
on a une partie entre Kawana forest bon
on a parlé beaucoup de beaucoup de
parents
ou alors j'ai mal compris
[Musique]
ça reste quand même solide la pollution
de merlan et puis un rognon il est il
fait pas mal de nul un petit peu
tranquille dans cet endroit je pense pas
qu'il est en vie vraiment de de Fight
non mais en fait ça se passe pas mal
pour lui enfin il a fait un bon tournoi
il force pas trop mais bon en même temps
tu vois il est plus toute fin c'est pas
un vétéran mais il a il a genre 40 ans
quand même un an donc c'est peut-être
dur je vais un tournoi de 4 de 13 rondes
à fond tous les jours quoi
voilà donc là bon bah oui nul normal
les blancs sont mieux mais on va jamais
même s'approcher du pion des cinq
je vous présente
qui vient me rendre visite mon petit
chat vu que là en train d'attendre toute
mignonne mais elle est pas si bien que
ça des fois elle pète des câbles
de tout quoi
on peut aller voir Magnus du coup elle
est Magnus
le chat est WGM
WGM le char Magnus
contre Google
verset 5
dans l'ouverture enfin il avait pas
encore joué C5 en fait quand on en
parlait
il y a eu des Français ok il voulait pas
voir ses quatre arrivées logiques
enfin je vais peut-être y aller d'autres
manières mais pourquoi pas
une batterie sur la diagonale blanche
sur H7 et donc du coup en fait un jour
en provoquant F6 et ben on ouvre quand
même les cases blanches
donc il a ramené le fond G3 donc voilà
il dit ok je te l'ai donné F6 gratuit
mais comme c'est un coup que juge comme
étant une faiblesse bah c'est pas si
gratuit que ça et un tempo donc gokash a
échangeant des trois ok bon
il le chasse machin H5 H4
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
bon j'aime quand même de mieux en mieux
la pollution blanche je t'avoue
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
quand même sur le long terme des
possibilités assez intéressantes comme
comme de jouer avec la 4 à 5
et bon j'ai eu le temps d'être en prise
pour l'instant donc c'est pas possible
je sais pas je m'impression qu'il y a
plus de flexibilité chez les Blancs
et
[Musique]
en fait on va dire
au vu des coups qu'on vient de faire
défiler que les blancs font des choses
et noir en position elle a même qui a 15
coups
5 x 4 prendre 3 ils ont baladé la dame
ils ont mis les tours au centre mais
c'est à peu près tout
les blancs bon ils ont un peu mieux
placé les tours ils ont fait H4 ils se
donnent deux trois petites cibles
donc j'ai l'impression de Carlson arrive
un peu plus à trouver
quoi faire plus d'idées dans la position
après donc plus concrètement dans ce qui
se passe
je pense ça va toujours pour les Noirs
mais c'est vrai que d'être là à regarder
si tu dois jamais être trop agréable
quoi
puisque le pion F2 était en surcharge
devait défendre G3 et E3 donc il part la
menace
très bien
si ça se trouve un jour c'est lui qui
fera un coup bizarre comme 4 pour couler
cette tour G3 bon pour l'instant ça va
pas du tout mais peut-être et tout est
très solide donc après ils s'apprête
justement à bouger le cavalier peut-être
vers F3 ou vers B3 D4 et où
ou faire Kylie B3 dame D1 et essayer de
faire H5 il peut aussi peut-être songer
faire j'ai trois rois G2 pour renforcer
un peu et avoir
des possibilités d'aller sur la première
rangée avec les pièces lourdes la dame
une tour quelque chose pour aller en H
peut-être il y a H5 H6 ou H5 déjà en
quoi il y a des petites idées et donc
côté nord faudrait trouver quoi faire
bon on aimerait bien attaquer ces trois
mais le problème c'est que il est bloqué
en B6 donc il y a une nouvelle fois
fuite au moins ça libère la tour C8 ça
va un peu blinder droit ok pourquoi pas
tu as l'impression que les blancs
peuvent améliorer la pollution un peu
comme ils veulent il y a plein de petits
coups pour améliorer alors que les Noirs
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué à vraiment
trouver un plan concret
dans la réaction
la création de quelque chose après ce
qui peut faire il y a pas l'air de
coûter trop cher c'est de doubler les
tours sur scène pour C6 ou tours aussi
et pour aller attaquer un petit peu ces
trois
salut à chou c'est pas avec l'interface
a changé c'est juste là on utilise les
échiquets DGT
pour poursuivre parce qu'en fait
cheescom il y a trop de monde dessus
c'est un peu un peu sauté alors tout le
chat là déconnectez-vous tous de chascom
s'il vous plaît pour nous connecter
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de monde et
puis il y a eu le record un peu de
fréquentation sur le site les gens
aiment tellement cheesecum que du coup
nous empêche de pouvoir stream les vent
donc
[Musique]
du coup on est obligé de passer par un
autre site donc ça c'est le site
officiel si vous voulez de
[Musique]
non bah de Servette quand tu quand tu
retransmets des parties tout le monde
passe par des j'étais en fait c'est le
site de retransmission officielle quoi
tu vois non mais c'est une blague les
gars
c'est pas ça qui va changer
petit c'est peut-être tout le monde se
déconnecte à un moment on va y arriver
on va demander à résilier votre
abonnement allez-y
je vais me faire taper sur les doigts
non mais j'ai vu abonnez-vous je
rigolais j'ai vu la la
sur Facebook
comme quoi dans la semaine ça a des
s’améliorer etc il y avait des ranges
qui étaient en train d'essayer
d'arranger les choses et donc bon bah
écoutez en fait c'est juste que là
sûrement ils ont pris le cours et que ok
c'est bon voilà
c'est ça bon après c'est cool voilà
c'est juste un
ou deux ou peut-être plusieurs jours
encore à vivre un peu dans les
conditions un peu particulières mais on
va on va trouver des solutions et puis
et puis voilà
en tout cas non mais là déjà c'est
complètement regardable quoi
le seul truc c'est qu'on peut pas faire
des flèches ni jouer des coups donc ça
malheureusement je peux pas trop
analyser c'est le seul pour moi problème
pour faire des des trucs qui partent ça
peut être aussi
j'ai fait capture de fenêtre
mais ouais au moins que je puisse
seulement colorer colorier des cases
c'est un peu compliqué non mais c'est un
peu compliqué
comme donc tu imagines bien le drama si
je vais sur les chaises c'est pas
possible juste mais sinon voilà
salut Steve salut Fab je débute l'échec
j'aimerais savoir quels sont vos
conseils lecture pour progresser tu
débutes d'échec donc du coup bon déjà
pour essayer la basse c'est vraiment
faire le maximum de tactique tu sais que
les exercices les problèmes que tu as
sur James com quand ça marche et ben
c'est hyper efficace hyper important
pour toi
et
du coup voilà en plus bon tu as
robinside qui me fait remarquer sur le
chat il y a eu un un
livre écrit par sa plume donc avec bien
sûr blesseries que tout le monde connaît
sur le chat
donc le livre comment s'appelle
exactement c'est progrès de l'échec même
quand on est débutant je crois que c'est
ça donc il y a le tome 2 qui est sorti
il y a quelques mois donc le tome 1 il
est pour
je crois jusqu'à 1400 il me semble
comment
c'est gagné aux échecs quelque chose un
très fort enfin tu vas gagner et non en
même temps tu vas progresser donc en
plus tu vas gagner tout en étant en plus
donc voilà mais ouais non c'est deux
très bons livres voilà donc
comme inside qui
a écrit ce livre
avec du coup Kevin bordi un blitstream
donc oui donc ça c'est deux très bons
bouquins et le tome 1 le tome 2 donc
quand tu débutes c'est vraiment parfait
et
voilà en plus il y avait je sais pas qui
avait la commande au bouquin ok bah
écoute nickel
donc n'hésite pas
que je voulais dire ouais non le livre
en plus ça change par rapport au livre
classique d'échec parce que c'est bien
publié une belle édition quoi c'est
Gallimard et donc il y a de la couleur
il y a une belle qualité de papier etc
donc c'est c'est plutôt cool
après évidemment il y a plein d'autres
livres et après faut que tu aies envie
de les lire parce que en fait je sais
maintenant nouvelle génération ils sont
peut-être plus format vidéo quoi mais
lire un livre d'échec c'est tu lis à ton
propre tempo tu vas revenir dessus
rejouer le truc enfin quand même pas mal
mais évidemment faut que ce soit un
format qui te plaise quoi j'ai envie de
dire
non mais c'est vrai que c'est sympa en
plus c'est bien écrit il y a les
anecdotes et puis vous savez que bon si
vous connaissez pas la plume de Robinson
en vrai c'est sympa parce que c'est
c'est pas écrit comme un livre d'échec
normal si vous voulez ce que des fois ça
peut être un petit peu sur le long terme
un peu ennuyant quoi et là c'est c'est
bien plus à dire joyeux et plus sympa à
lire donc franchement n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à
à vous procurer ce livre donc à deux
tomes donc c'est deux tomes et puis
et puis vous nous direz un petit peu des
nouvelles
donc il tour à 5 de Magnus donc les
pions à cette emprise on peut pas jouer
le pion à 6 parce que je perdrai le
cavalier avec Madame
et du coup il faut défendre quand même
ce petit pion je pense comment est-ce
que je peux le défendre à ce que fout
c'est 5 c'est un menace je suis pas sûr
vous voyez que fou c'est 5
si je mets le foot case noire en cessé
et ben j'aurai une petite on va dire
découverte sur la tour à 7 mais il faut
voir si c'est possible je pense que ça
peut non c'est non ça n'est pas je vais
à loucher parce que fou c'est 5
tours-pompions à 7
et je pensais à cavalier noir en C4 qui
vient en fait découvrir la tour avec le
fouet 5 et sur tout reprend B7 et ben je
pensais avoir un point de cavaler prend
des deux sachant que sur ton point il y
a un clouage sur la dame bien mais ce
qui se passe c'est qu'en fait la tour B7
défendra aussi la dame bien
je suis désolé de pas pouvoir faire des
flèches
tu reprends à 7 et cavaliers C4
du coup vous jouez C4 dès maintenant
avec l'idée que sur tu reprends à 7 et
bah il y a qu'un palier prend cavalier
et tout reprend cavalier sera interdit
parce qu'il y aura en fait gratuit et du
coup peut-être
tu peux manger et puis on prend et
tourner
on a un problème parce qu'en fin de
vente on se retrouve avec A7 et B7
attaqué et je vois pas trop de moyen de
défendre les deux
si ça se trouve on a un coup comme dame
G4 ou des coups bizarres mais je sais
pas ça sent pas trop bon mais peut-être
qu'il y a une C4 qui prend tout reprend
c'est une manière de défendre parce que
bon on va me prendre les sacs ça va pas
il y a le tour d'être en l'air et sur je
retour reprends des 5 et bon ben logique
il y a quand même te repenser 3
et peut-être que ça tient
grâce à ça enfin bon ça reste la fièvre
ça reste tactique et donc bon on oublie
vite arrivé un petit coup intermédiaire
un truc mais peut-être peut-être que
c'est une manière d'essayer de la tenir
après sur qui est C4 qui prend tout
reprend aussi checker s'il y a pas un
coup comme je sais pas d'âme B5 dame
prend des trois dans le point 8
mais bon et peut-être fou des 6 quoi
donc
mais bon en tout cas les noirs
bon après est-ce qu'on peut bêtement
faire à 6 il faut regarder parce que bon
il y a toujours cette histoire de
tourner trois qui doit être défendu pour
l'instant
est possible tout à l'heure j'ai que
c'était pas possible mais du coup je me
suis fait reprendre par chaise comme fr
lui-même en fait tu racisme d'arme ici
d'un point cavalier ne serait pas
forcément bon à cause de dame prend tout
en Détroit j'ai oublié qu'on va être la
dame défendait la tour et que c'est pas
un parterre vraiment à tour avec avec
les Blancs donc du coup à 6 reste une
possibilité
et évidemment on est fragile côté noir
c'est-à-dire que dès que c'est le tour
des trois sera défendu ou qu'elle
bougera
plus défendu il y a des derrière donc
il va falloir trouver un coup précis
côté nord
donc Carlson blanc cassenal est blanc
vous voyez le premier écrit a toujours
les blancs donc du coup vous avez à
gauche un blanc noir et les couleurs
parce que toi ça te force à
bouger en tant qu'une feignasse je le
connais pendant X
qui débutent ou quoi c'est un peu
dommage de papa avoir des flèches
c'est plus facile en fait pour vraiment
comprendre tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on
raconte
alors on va voir si on a d'autres
parties parce que là on reste longtemps
sur la même
Prague du coup et carwana en 3 4 5 6 3 4
5 6 donc du coup
pratiquement l'impression
avec son petit pion en BK
mais je suis pas sûr que ça soit oh ça
peut être sympa si j'arrive à faire
cavaler des cartes avec les Blancs ça
peut être un petit pressing peut-être
parce qu'il y a aussi
je pensais à 5 mais
bon là à 5 ça marchera pas mais en fait
l'idée j'aimerais essayer de de
provoquer un bécran à 5 pour un cavalier
prend S5
donc
pour l'instant c'est pas possible mais
il y a un petit pressing parce qu'on
voit que le pion à 7 beau boss c'est un
pion qui est isolé sur la colonne de ma
tour et de Madame le pion c'est 6 des
Noirs c'est un pion qu'il faut
surveiller tout le temps
et bon le pion B4 aussi mais vous voyez
que la dame noire a du mal à venir
charger le plan de 4 et pour l'instant
j'ai un cadeau aussi qui défend donc
cavaler des quatre je parlais blanc pour
être une bonne idée pour justement aller
bien cavalier et ramener un autre pion
vers le centre et du coup essayer de
pousser mais je suis pas sûr enfin je
sais pas comment on pourrait vraiment
réussir à
à progresser mais en tout cas c'est
clair que les banques sont beaucoup
mieux et les blancs a priori joue pour
deux résultats quoi je pense il y a pas
trop trop ouais il y a pas trop de monde
où je vois perdre ici
on croisait
pas grand-chose
ça tient mais bon on va voir
un petit peu des pièces bizarre
au coup d'avant donc si c'est pour jouer
Damas 5 maintenant
disons je m'y attend pas mais
en fait
[Musique]
peut-être qu'il veut le jeu cahier des 4
du coup
mais c'est vrai que des quatre là
maintenant je suis pas fan parce que
elle va les prendre puis on prend je
sens que tu m'écoute juste par rien
[Musique]
on va voir
pas évident mais oui en tout cas les
blancs il reste rien mais ce qui peut
vraiment accomplir quelque chose
après on peut voir il peut jouer un coup
comme j'ai trois moi j'ai deux H4
comment ça bouge un peu de trois trucs
monter un peu
avant que leur font rien tu essaies
d'améliorer et tu vois ce que ça donne
après mais je sais pas trop juste qu'on
peut aller après dans l'idéal on est
moins chasser ce qu'il y avait les deux
aussi c'est lui qui avait mis en D4 mais
arrivé à faire F4 G4 F5 ça a l'air trop
compliqué parce qu'on explose notre
propre roi et donc dame G3 arrive direct
mais oui dans l'idéal on aimerait faire
mais comment comment y arriver dur
peut-être une autre idée après c'est
d'essayer de tourner un E4 échanger
ok bon
tu vois c'est pas des plans
extraordinaires je propose c'est des
petites idées comme ça pour jouer un peu
mais je pense c'est assez solide quoi
mais ouais par contre peut-être beaucoup
mieux peut-être gagnant je sais pas
enfin toi on a plus les barres en plus
rien donc c'est dur à dire mais
possible soit grave pour pH ce qui se
passe après le tour à 5 plus moins
inquiété par la pression de caravane on
va dire
même si visuellement ok ça a l'air
sympathique pour les blancs
alors du coup est-ce qu'on peut aller
voir un peu autre chose donc on avait du
coup rapport
alors là je trouve que les Noirs ont
l'air pas mal du tout ouais ouais ça se
passe pas mal je crois que c'est plus ou
moins arrivé à accomplir leur objectif
de l'invasion des cases blanches le fou
en E4 qui empêche le roi de bouger et la
colonne enfin la diagonale noire c'est
un H6 qui va finir par s'ouvrir alors on
s'est arrêté on s'est arrêté à G5 et on
avait dit que la menace était G4 donc il
y a eu H3 qui empêche G4 mais pas du
tout en fait parce que du coup h3g4 il y
aura d'arme prend tour donc je ne peux
je ne peux pas ici
à manger
du coup ici on a eu grand rock et en
fait je pense que sur la prise ici à
Tourcoing
et du coup après tu veux jouer F3 et ton
plan normal donc les Noirs
il y a F3 avec les Blancs et 4 et là du
coup on est très très bien avec les
noirs avec les blancs
en gros
il fait un coup comme ça enfin il fait
il maintient cette du coup on va dire
parce que je prends G4 on peut pas si on
fait j'ai trois par chasser la lame il
va juste rester sur la colonnage mais
une fois qu'il y a plus plongée d'eau on
aura plus jamais froid et puis bah en
fait ça sert à quoi ton quoi H3 avec tes
tours sont pas connectés et que voilà
[Musique]
en fait c'est vraiment ça
qui va empêcher encore une fois F3 je
contrôle la case
là enlever une flèche blanche
[Musique]
du couteau géant il y a eu cavaler des 7
et bon c'est un peu bizarre ce qui fait
que blanc il fait dame deux dames tu as
l'impression que c'est pas trop ce qu'il
fait
prise du coup en H3
parce que
faire fou le fou blanc en E2 pour venir
clouer la le pion G4 donc il y a eu que
je prends H3
du coup d'Amal 6
on récupère en H3 grand rock
mais bon
après je voudrais m'en fous voilà donc
ça va pas et puis du coup bon on va
arriver à la pression de la partie tour
j'ai été attaque le fou F5 le défend je
sais pas comment récupérer pour le coup
parce que c'était pas tellement un coup
que les Noirs enfin ils ont bien envie
de le faire
de toute façon donc
toujours quoi sinon je sais pas ce que
je joue je crois qu'on est pas bien mais
en fait on donne juste F5 gratuit par
rapport à ton projet direct
pas de bonne idée il fait un truc parce
qu'il faut quand même jouer un coin jour
mais
on en est là OK
là du coup il faut faire un truc parce
que effectivement comme tu le dis si le
fou s'en va par exemple en B7 blanc vont
réussir à jouer 4 et là du coup bah bon
ça reste encore pas simple parce que le
purge 5 tu vas tomber etc mais peut-être
que il réussiront un petit peu à sortir
un peu de leur pétrin là
ici il est possible qu'il y ait une
tactique
quand même pour
n'importe quoi
en fait
d'en prendre 5
priori c'est un bon coup quoi
[Rires]
en C2 échec protégé par le fou il y
aurait des découvertes de partout ce
serait ce serait
catastrophique donc là maintenant il
faut défendre le pion F3 qui a l'air
d'être perdu parce que maintenant
ça vient tous les côtés là je pense ça
va être abandon
un truc original en posant des problèmes
qu'on a pas l'habitude de voir pour les
blancs là ce G5 rapide et il a mais
ouais c'est pas mal quoi
et
il s'est fait un peu piétiné quoi
j'allais dire dans la partie donc à moi
qui a une gaffe ou quoi mais genre ça a
l'air juste gagné pour le noir et il
doit y aller bonne partie franchement
pas mal peut-être une partie finir dans
des livres sur la Nimzo sur la stratégie
machin parce que là c'est ouais ça me
fait penser à des vieilles parties en
fait il a joué fait faim
et puis si on veut me faire d'un point
F3 on a le droit quoi enfin donc
on va voir la priorité du jour il me
semble que ça a répété
la vidéo sur sur irigazie parce que je
sais que le chat aime beaucoup quand ça
abandonne c'est beaucoup voir les
joueurs les joueurs abandonnés
donc on dirait donc là je vous mets la
partie de
erikasi blanc contre rapport
et puis après on ira voir 45 je sais pas
il me semble que ça répétait alors j'ai
pas vérifié encore mais après quand ça
va vouloir sûrement la jouer mais
il me semble que ça répétait un petit
peu
les couteau échec on va voir Robert qui
va arriver
ou avant d'abondance soit bonsoir
[Rires]
abandon
mais par contre moi je la caméra qui qui
veut plus ah oui c'est bon vous êtes
peut-être le voir en direct du coup
peut-être
normalement oui
sur le truc
mais
[Musique]
de jouer
on a encore F5 et en fait
du coup il y a on a dû on a un pied de
retard même sur la vidéo c'est c'est
bizarre
il peut pouvoir les voir abandonner quoi
du coup ça va mettre 10 ans encore pour
abandonner après peut-être que c'est
possible
en fait c'est possible qu'on a 15
minutes d'avance
[Rires]
mais peut-être que c'est un lien qui
sont secret tu vois
je pense c'est ça je pense c'est un lien
que j'étais à secret avec leur gars quoi
et ils m'ont passé parce qu'on a un
problème de retransmission et du coup du
coup en vrai si nous le passe comme ça
publiquement c'est quand même la règle
enquêtrice quoi
du coup il nous laisse tricher pour
qu'on puisse faire l'événement c'est
cool
donc une bonne idée d'avoir ce délai
enfin c'est très bien sur les caméras et
aussi sur
[Musique]
sur
les parties c'est ça permet de d'éviter
une aide extérieure etc
et compagnie mais malheureusement neiman
c'est loin d'être le seul il y a des
trucs qui sont pas été publiés ou quoi
mais bon voilà et donc je pense ça doit
être la norme maintenant pour vraiment
faire au mieux éviter
[Musique]
sur d'autres sites à côté et c'est vrai
que du coup
je suis en avance par rapport à d'autres
sites donc je me disais tiens
bon mais à quel point on avance je crois
qu'on a 15 minutes d'avance
et c'est comme tu vois quand tu vas sur
télescom en fait et que tu vas sur les
résultats il y a la partage je vous
montre les résultats
match et en fait là vous allez voir
tu vois
ergy rapport et le problème c'est que
moi en fait vu que j'ai 15 minutes de
retard je ne sais pas et du coup quand
je montre les matchs bah très souvent je
me spoiler un résultat avant de l'avoir
quoi tu vois et parce que du coup ben là
en fait ça c'est bon c'est comme le sait
le résultat est donc le mec directement
en fait je pense qu'il pourrait attendre
un quart d'heure avant de le mettre
parce que du coup nous on est tous
spoilés quoi dès qu'on a tu regardes par
amour
[Musique]
là je vous mets la caméra vous allez
voir tous les deux qui sont en train de
réfléchir et c'est quoi la caméra c'est
par Ham c'est 7 regardez bien mais la
caméra elle est joueur bah voilà ils
sont ils sont concentrés quoi et là je
vais mettre la partie
c'est auparable
et voilà voilà cela ça a fait nul par
contre parce qu'ils le savent mais
tout à l'heure je regardais et je voyais
que il y avait une je crois que le noir
avait un bel avantage un peu des cinq
mais bon prise prise donc il y a une
prise qui a validé F2
[Musique]
a priori mais bon si ça se trouve
le fou il s'en va bouffe des seins
[Musique]
quand même tu reprends 3 ça peut ça peut
mal tourner les gars
ok bon
il y a juste DAMS
toutes les minutes ça marche
du coup tout à l'heure j'ai vu que il
m'a semblé voir peut-être que c'est que
le retard annonce le retard je pense que
j'avais eu sur un autre site qui m'avait
dit que venait de jouer et du coup je me
suis dit tiens ça répétait mais en fait
du coup je savais pas encore que j'avais
du du fin que j'avais pas la carte de
délai
parce que la tour des trois était en
prise parce que j'aime bien dans la
défense E4 il joue pour intercepter la
dame G6 donc je sais pas c'était le seul
coup d'être H55
exactement c'est un truc quand même
mentionné plus tôt
j'ai trop attaques la dame enlève à toi
taquet et laisse le cab600 l'air ils ont
été récupéré
en prise en en B6 le cavalier noir donc
il a fait qui est C4 donc il a enlevé ce
qui va aller en prise il est venu en C4
et du coup les blancs maintenant ont
plusieurs options peuvent prendre des
cinq B7 peuvent prendre ces quatre
avec le pion non
on peut oui
qui serait un découle et plus logique
peut-être c'est ce qui vient de faire
mais
prendre des deux et prise de 4 quoi
cavaler deux et on sait pas si on prend
de la tour du fou
dans tous les cas on risque de manger 4
prochain coup même peut-être voir C3 on
voit comment tu vas manger
pas si mal que ça
ouais je sais pas oui enfin bon bah ça
se trouve il a trouvé une belle défense
avec son assis qui est C4 après
je sais pas tu vois
là ouais donc il prend des autres
on a quand même envie de manger de du
foot peut-être pour éviter tous les
échanges et le plan C3 je sais pas son
dame prend le 4
dans la position ou toujours cavalier
prendre les deux faut prendre des deux
d'un cadre il y a même du fou c'est 5
dans la reine qui peut tu vois sur ton
process 5 je dois prendre des trois
enfin il y a des idées comme ça quoi
donc avoir alors attends je vais juste
mettre la caméra sur ma venue on me la
demande
retard ouais dans la caméra
[Musique]
t'inquiète je fais attention à ça
OK
mais au moins il essaie de provoquer des
petits problèmes
les petits problèmes concrets quoi
ouais donc ton dessin en tout cas
intéressant
et je pense que Google en tout cas c'est
le sentiment que cette position
l'impression qu'il est qu'il est pas mal
maintenant il est arrivé
un pion
avec la série de coups clairement pas
mais il faut avoir un petit peu un petit
peu gamer et Abdou c'est le leader pour
l'instant qui a un point d'avance sur sa
poursuivant donc c'est poursuivant qui
sont
guéris et on avait dit pardon
j'ai un petit trou de mémoire
et donc
ce qui a fait nul et guéri qui avait une
partie chaude entre Jean qu'on va voir
juste après
et
du coup
[Musique]
du coup tours c'est ça donc une huile de
réussite une bonne nouvelle pour lui vu
qu'il a beau il vous contre un
adversaire assez fort
nul les clés noirs c'est quand même à ce
niveau là c'est important
[Musique]
mais bon un peu quoi c'est un peu faible
je suis d'accord ah les blancs elle peut
te mettre une tour après ils vont tout
prendre mettre une tour en décises
faites le C5 en D3 en F4 et mettre une
petite pression alors je suis convaincu
que si ça défend bien ça va défendre et
en tout cas clairement c'est plus l'élan
qui peuvent prétendre un petit peu faire
un truc que les noirs
[Musique]
et le Cavalier Blanc le transférer sur
la case F4 de là il pourra attaquer le
pion des 5 et ça sera un peu ça
évidemment si on gagne des cinq après
c'est une autre histoire
donc on m'a demandé sur le chat un petit
un petit résumé
on n'a pas les déchets quelque chose
comme voilà petit résumé du truc on a
des petits problèmes de retransmission
enfin le
site est un petit peu
un petit peu en fait il est très
fréquenté et du coup ça fait bugger le
site
du coup au niveau des résultats je vais
te mettre les résultats ici alors
t'afficher
non 3
qui bon qui est un peu moins bien qui va
essayer de tenir il y a Carlsen qui est
une situation similaire mais lui dans le
côté blanc contre Google
mettre un peu mieux pour pour Magnus qui
va essayer de la pression donc ça c'est
pour le tableau il y a une partie chaude
on sait pas où ça en est entre digne et
grisa c'est un petit pressing blanc
de toute façon on va on va revenir un
peu sur les parties on va vous montrer
un peu tout ça
mais un petit pressing pour pour Prague
mais rien de bien méchant on pensait que
c'était possible que
Fabi
défendent juste tranquillement quoi
le stream qui est très fréquenté il
pourrait y avoir 50 000 personnes ça
changera rien c'est le site la
plateforme quoi qui
qui pose problème parce que ils ont
battu leur record de de d'inscription de
de personnes qui jouent en ligne en
direct ou quoi et ça leur fait cracher
un peu les serveurs mais genre 16000
personnes sur un stream c'est pas beau
enfin c'est pas beaucoup en plus pour
instrument
ça c'est pas un problème c'est c'est
bien c'est comme le site en lui-même et
je ne peux pas accéder à la
retransmission du site c'est juste
mais je sais pas en fait c'est bon je
sais pas du tout pourquoi là d'un coup
il y a un regain parce qu'à l'époque du
confinement
des premiers enfin des streams Gambie ça
je comprenais très bien et alors là je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé à récemment
et leur histoire de mitaines ils sont
tous je sais pas pourquoi ils sont très
heureux de ça hyper bien marché
juste un ordi ou tu as mis une tête de
chat ou un poisson
sans parler de partout c'était
fantastique
et alors je sais pas c'est peut-être ça
pour le coup croyez-le ou non et sinon
je sais pas d'où viennent ces gens mais
à mon avis l'histoire de miton ça a
clairement aidé
S
donc gère l'autre si tout ça joue c'est
une pièce on va dire
donc je sais pas en fait je sais pas
quoi vous dire je suis pas d'où sortent
ces gens qui viennent s'additionner
on vient de passer on vient de commencer
une nouvelle année
[Musique]
et du coup
pas un gros truc mais en fait ouais je
peux pas trop dire quels sont ces choses
cumulées autant en 2020 je pouvais dire
enfin j'avais ma petite idée là j'en
sais rien
il s'est passé quoi on va revenir un peu
cette partie qui était hyper intéressant
[Musique]
qui menace de faire une belle une belle
fourchette en E3 et il a juste bougé la
tour il défend pas le pion 3 alors du
coup attends juste si jamais je joue un
coup comme style Dame des deux
[Musique]
un peu ce que j'ai vu
Dame des deux qui
défend depuis 3 il pourrait y avoir
peut-être
un cabas et prend le 3
et sur dame prend le 3 et ben il y a
cavalier F3 échec qui avec une
découverte sur la tour d'ailleurs tour 3
mais là je pourrais faire d'un point
cavalier faut prendre d'âme et pour
prendre et je gagne quand même trois
pièces pour la dame donc généralement
trois pièces c'est quand même pas mal
surtout quand je contrôle vraiment tous
les chéquiers donc ça m'a l'air pas mal
pour les blancs mais peut-être que ce
qu'il avait eu peur c'est que son
cavalier F5 si ce Dame des deux
peut-être que du coup cavalier prend C4
suivi de cavaliers tout à l'heure dans
le chat on me l'a demandé si c'était
jouable peut-être que ici ça l'est je
sais pas en tout cas la jetons des deux
et du coup il laisse le pion E3 en prise
sur Cavalo 3 il est juste dit que je
m'en fous un peu et du coup on va
échanger et du coup ce pion en trois de
toute façon il était faible et du coup
maintenant je gagne un peu l'initiative
je fais des menaces donc pourquoi pas
qui vient de mettre aux échecs ces
dernières années je tombais sur beaucoup
de vidéos sur YouTube
j'ai pris goût et ouais mais je pense
que au fur et à mesure en fait il y a
beaucoup de gens qui se lancent sur sur
Youtube aussi en streaming etc et c'est
vrai que Ben au final
mais bon après là pourquoi maintenant
je crois que c'est
pas du tout es isolé mais en fait a
priori là d'un coup il y a eu un énorme
afflux pas des gens comme toi il y en a
chaque mois on va dire c'est il doit y
avoir voilà je pense un certain nombre
chaque fois d'être un mois un peu plus
un mois un peu moins mais plus ou moins
doit se lisser quoi très longtemps donc
ils savent peut-être que chaque mois ils
ont 10 000 nouveaux usagers je sais pas
je viens chiffre au hasard mais là genre
c'est peut-être un truc à 100000 d'un
coup ils sont arrivés je prends des
chiffres au hasard j'en sais rien c'est
pas forcément ça les proportions ni les
chiffres mais il y a un truc
complètement disproportionné que c'est
passé et il s'y attendait pas forcément
je pense et voilà mais c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle dans l'ensemble d'avoir
des nouveaux membres ça il y a pas de
souci mais ouais faut avoir les
infrastructures qui tiennent le choc
quoi et là pour le coup c'est un peu le
coup de surprise donc ils vont réparer
tout ça j'en suis persuadé mais
après je suis pas sûr qu'avec par
rapport au rachat les gens ils ont
changé de plateforme parce que Chris 24
par exemple existe toujours donc
toujours et bon on va comme je disais
c'est franchement c'était assez rare les
gens qui jouent dessus
c'est pas connu pour être une zone de
jeu enfin toujours
une zone je pense que au niveau des
retransmissions c'était plutôt bien
l'interface
mais bon après voilà je sais pas tu vois
je pense pas que ce soit ça parce que du
coup rien n'a changé en fait des sites
reste ce qu'ils sont quoi
non mais pour le coup je sais pas quoi
répondre donc en fait on n'en sait rien
6 cavaliers 4 tacos et le fou prend ses
cadres donc là du coup dirige je pense
juste qu'il est juste mal en fait de
manière générale tu vois les cases
centrales sont vraiment pour les blancs
les pièces noires jouent pas et du coup
il est assez en fait de d'échanger enfin
le sacrifier les pions enfin ces pièces
pour une qualité avec des pions
donc avoir Bay prend cavaler prendre un
bouge qu'elle va les prendre tour d'un
pont cavalier
matériellement tu as quand même trois
pions et une tour pour deux pièces mais
c'est vrai que tes pièces sont un peu
éloignées quand tu as la tour à huile
par exemple et même ta structure de pion
j'ai un pion A4 quand même qui bloque le
pion B7 et c'est 5 j'ai du mal à
vraiment voir ton contre jeu avec les
avec les Blancs j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
les blancs
[Musique]
des deux peut-être dame 5
qui se regarde prioritairement lui il a
même pas pris il a fait de toi F2
mais il a toujours le même jeu sympa
mais en fait là si vous voyez ça dépend
de position un peu atypique c'est assez
marrant parce que vous voyez des pièces
parcs qui sont toutes très mal placées
vous voyez la tour à 8 le X6 le cavalier
5 qui donne un cloué parce que si il
bouge j'aurais dû me prendre et cette
matte les pièces qui ne jouent pas la
dame B8 c'est une horreur et il y a de
plus en plus pour les Noirs mais ils
sont limites en 11 exemples en fait pas
bouger
ma tour sur la 7ème rangée vous savez
que colonne ouverte ton septième c'est
super bien et sur cavalier prend tour
des sets ben comme par magie on l'a dit
tout à l'heure il y a le clavier cloué
quoi donc attends
toujours d'un projet Z donc en fait
tourner cette pensée juste abandon donc
je pense qu'il faut paraître tourner
cette et fou dessin comme tu me dis à
part vérifier
d'ailleurs peut-être même que ton pointe
tiens bon je pense pas mais voyons en
fait il y a plein de thèmes sur F7 avec
le fou des 5 etc attendez 7 et on pense
que du coup dame C7 doit être
obligatoire pour empêcher tour de cette
donc Ding on va enfin
on peut pas voir moins de matériel être
gagnant oui en fait Eva c'est clair en
fait
quand tu compares les pièces tu imagines
bien que la tour qui est bloquée en A8
une tour en fait c'est ça vaut 5 points
mais t'imagines bien que la tour à 8 sur
la position elle veut pas autant de
points que la tour en F2 par exemple tu
vois ma tour en F2 elle fait des vrais
menaces elle est vraiment bien placée
elle a la colonne ouvertes en fait elles
ont pas les mêmes les mêmes possibilités
et donc du coup
il y a la valeur vraiment on veut dire
officielle des pièces mais après quand
tu es en partie la valeur peut varier
selon la position
et là quand tu vas la tour à 8 quand tu
as le foie à 6 quand tu vois les pièces
des Noirs
c'est vrai qu'il y a deux pions de plus
pour le noir mais en termes de position
les Blancs ont beaucoup plus de
possibilités des pièces beaucoup plus
actives et du coup voilà donc ici digne
il a sacrifié les pions pour justement
avoir une position très ouverte à
l'active donc
du coup voilà quoi
donc bien sûr
je vois quelqu'un dans le chat c'est lui
qui l'a analysé l'ordi qu'en fait à
priori c'est plus deux enfin que ça va
pour une heure qui a pas de visuellement
c'est cool mais qu'il y a pas de trucs
concrets mais
ben écoute on verra si on pratique guéri
trouve tous les bons coups de défense
les deux genres risque de manquer un peu
de temps enfin je garde la digne il a
moins de 10 minutes guéri il arrive au
quart d'heure il se dit coup c'est bon
enfin je vais vite un peu et donc dans
des positions compliquées comme ça ils
peuvent partir à la faute l'un ou
l'autre quoi donc c'est encore rien fait
quoi
en tout cas en pratique moi si je devais
choisir je prends les Noirs je prends
les blancs tous les jours
je prends les blancs tous les jours
parce que c'est une position qui m'a
l'air plus facile à jouer pour les
blancs parce que les coupes blancs sont
assez simples tu vois par contre par
contre les Noirs
[Musique]
il faut être pressé en défense et bon la
moindre petite moi un petit problème ça
peut te mettre clairement dedans en fait
donc à voir mais en tout cas c'est clair
qu'ici
après l'ordinateur
c'est une chose mais en plus les les
joueurs jouent beaucoup beaucoup
d'ailleurs de coups de coups d'ordi
enfin c'est assez incroyable quand tu
vois 45 jouer ou quoi tu vois ils ont un
portage de de
coup d'ordi qui est assez monstrueux
quoi
et du coup
très bien quoi c'est Damien tour du
monde c'est clair mais par exemple toi
tu me donnes cette position avec les
Noirs contre Ding bah il se peut que je
perde en cinq coups quoi
aussi bien je perds en cinq coups quoi
et en fait qui arrive elle a gagné quoi
ils vont se défendre d'une manière juste
monstrueuse alors que nous on va pas
avoir un dixième de ce que Ding et guéri
vont calculer et ça manque un petit peu
à la différence de niveau entre tous
entre tous les joueurs et tout ça quoi
[Musique]
en tout cas j'aime beaucoup la pose de
Ding c'est une partie qui est assez
chaude en plus Guiri qui est un des
leaders du tournoi il est il est un des
poursuivants d'Abdou donc une victoire
de guéri pour elle vraiment le remettre
clairement dans la course
[Musique]
à condition que que Abdou arrive à tenir
sa finale parce qu'on en a quand même
c'est pas simple encore tu vois
le plan qu'on a indiqué il va ramener le
caler vers 4
tac tac ok on fait voir bon ok
il va juste défendre son pion donc après
bon déjà il y aura fait le max le roi
arrive de faire mieux après faut avoir
absorbé 7 juste bon bref cette et
d'avoir en fait ouais c'est con que le
pion se ranger 3 tu vois tu le mettras
en H4 ce serait mieux tu stabiliseras le
cavalier tu as le droit qui pourrait
bouger ça tu peux manger cinq à tout
moment
description ça c'est un conseil dans le
chat
faites attention ne pas trop trop bouger
les pions non plus n'importe comment
parce qu'un plan ça recule pas et là par
exemple wa F3 si les Noirs jouent G5
alors j'en sais rien faut analyser mais
j'ai 5 par exemple pour être un coup qui
pourrait être faible pour les Noirs
parce qu'en fait ça va donner enfin ça
va faire cela et puis quoi par exemple
ici j'ai 5 pour les Noirs c'est les
Blancs jouent par exemple je sais pas
moi genre G4 peut-être que du coup il va
avoir plein de trous sans casse blanche
autour du pion G5 et que Ben au final le
plus on va il va tomber un jour etc donc
vraiment dans ces positions là vous
jouez les pions que si c'est vraiment
absolument nécessaire et éviter de
bouger les pions un peu pour rien en
fait essayer de garder vos petites
un petit coup de pion quand c'est
obligatoire c'est un peu des jokers quoi
vraiment
je
j'ai peur même pour les noirs
parce que c'est super le pion dessin
tu es pas bien
tu es pas bien tu parles comme ça mais
il faut y arriver encore tu vois faire
bref 4 il faut faire roi E5 mettre le
Cavaillon F4 c'est pas simple de mettre
tout ça en place si j'arrive à le faire
avec ton B2 ou quelque chose mais
[Musique]
tout à l'heure
on est arrêté à Damas
je sais plus une dame enquête
les Noirs OK
ils tournent un peu les pièces bon c'est
pas pour essayer de jouer un petit peu
et que Prague bon bah il joue des trucs
parce qu'il voit qu'il est il a pas trop
d'idées de ce qu'il doit faire voilà
ouais après maintenant
on est arrêté on est arrivé au 40e coup
donc du coup le genre va voir 50 minutes
de rajout pour terminer la partie
un petit truc quand même pour nous faire
plaisir etc
toujours à 7h30 à la partie de Google
en plus c'était important pour pour qui
va gagner le temps cette partie donc ah
oui bon ça franchement je suis content
mais au final ça offert la première
victoire à Google
c'était un de mes compagnon de club tu
sais on avait fait ensemble en Top 12
donc je le connais bien quoi content qui
gagne quoi
mais c'est vrai que bon 7h30 gagne
en plus il avait en plus on a de la
chance parce que par exemple pouvait
pouvait encore tourner quoi dans la
finale et il a complètement gaffé un
coup ce qui a fait qui en fait ce matin
donc la partie aurait pu durer un peu
plus un peu plus longtemps que cette
heure et demi
donc voilà bon on prend des cas du coup
[Musique]
et alors les chances de dames je pense
pas que ça serait forcément l'idéal
en fait en fait si
parce que d'un point de cas tu prends
des quatre ton B8
et je vais jouer à 5 bon c'est peut-être
tu vas jouer tour à 4
mais je monte mon roi
en gros ouais faut voir concrètement en
fait ce que tu veux pas avec les Noirs
c'est faire de me prendre des Caps puis
on prend des quatre je repasse jouez
Clément fasse tout raciste qui était la
tour en C7 donc soit passif chiante et
là les blancs
qui crée le pion passé et bon on va
gagner quoi
je m'en fous je prends B4 non mais c'est
ça en fait là si tu as tombé 7 enfin tu
joues un coup que tu joues pas rien ça
change pas mal de choses et
donc c'est ça vérifié bon là il a le
temps il a une heure
mais non
raciste en B4 tours ces 6 sort D4 mais
en plus donc et
boum boum torbet ça toi donc faut
probablement faire tour à 4 mais là
sûrement que le roi va avoir le temps de
venir
en B8
et que ça ça devrait le faire donc
probablement que c'est possible
d'échanger après peut-être qu'un autre
coup c'est tour B7 maintenant
[Musique]
je veux dire tu vois c'est mieux
après
et voilà donc
plus dur et passer je sais pas
moi bien mais là ça doit aller juste
sans trop de mal quoi quel que soit je
pense que ça va vous devrez être un nul
mais ça va encore jouer un petit peu
parce que il a il a une toute petite
chance minuscule donc à ce niveau là
quand tu as une petite chance il faut la
jouer
alors du coup bah 45 c'est vraiment
qu'on n'est pas allé le voir car c'est
une Gou Kech salut mala
comment il se passe mal à
MG6
[Musique]
est-ce que c'était une surprise et ben
non
c'est pas grave
on est parti hein
donc ça si ça en avait vu donc il y a eu
4 qui est C4 tours bien donc cet arrêté
ici
comme on avait dit aussi d'un pronom 4
il a pas mangé le 7
il a juste voulu défendre le pion H4 ici
mais qui peut être utile s'il a envie de
l'envoyer en H5 H6 ou créer un peu de
brèche c'est vrai que on prend B7 les
marques freinage 4
le renard est plus safe
après je sais pas enfin ok on va voir
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ici
bien passé mais bon il y a toujours un
pressing blanc dans cette partie
avec il y a toujours le petit H6 blanc
qui peut partir bon bien je suis noir du
coup pour empêcher que les Blancs
fassent H6 et même est casser un peu la
structure j'ai toujours 17 avec les
banques qui veut être arrivé pour
s'activer ici et le fouet qui a un peu
passif donc du coup bon il y a un léger
pressing pour pour blanc mais je suis
pas sûr que ça suffise
je pense que je pense que Google a
réussi à ici à
moi
peut-être avec les Blancs il va essayer
d'aller planter une tour en 6 je sais
pas trop pourquoi mais pourquoi pas et
c'est pas évident parce qu'en fait
souvent en plus on peut se dire que dans
les finales ça peut être un truc mieux
pour les blondes alors fixer les pions
adverse pour quasiment comme ça mais il
y a plus beaucoup de pions en fait donc
je suis pas sûr je pense pas que ça
puisse suffire en fait après tendre à
quoi que ce soit ça aurait pu être le
cas s'il y avait genre 3 pions chacun
des dames je peux dire ouais bon dans
une finale de fou pour pouvoir c'est
passif là-bas je peux faire autre chose
ailleurs faire peut-être des ruptures
etc mais là comme ça
il y a peut-être pas assez de l'autre
côté donc
ça doit aller pour les noirs
c'est solide voilà là bon déjà peut-être
un coup comme tour C5 peut être
envisageable pour les noirs
juste pour la fin un peu de pression sur
sur H5 donc
[Musique]
voilà pas si simple après ce que
non ça va enfin juste ça va je pense
mais bon ok
un petit peu embêtant
alors si vous êtes des parties que vous
voulez voir vous êtes des questions ou
quoi que ce soit n'hésitez pas à nous
demander soit des parties sur fin des
questions pardon sur
sur les positions
ou sur
nous si vous voulez me parler n'hésitez
pas de toute façon là il se passe pas
grand chose pour l'instant ça bouge
vraiment pas à pas donc n'hésitez pas en
tout cas nous
à nous poser des questions nous parler
point d'interrogation mais en fait oui
c'est un couple en G4 mais bon dans la
position de Carlson mais en fait les
normes vont juste faire un coup de
droits ils vont pas te laisser faire
quoi
donc
enfin une question mais
alors le D alors du coup j'ai perdu mes
j'avais un dé à côté de moi mais j'avais
tout changé
malheureusement je peux pas te dire je
suis désolé
ça dépend de l'intensité du fable
mais beaucoup dehors en général
un projet pour 2023 bah j'en ai pas
tellement
enfin j'en ai pas mal mais rien de fou
quoi tu vois
rien qui va te déchaîner la chronique
pour les Parisiens le meilleur club de
chaque pour adultes bah écoute il y en a
plusieurs à Paris ou dans la région ça
peut aussi simplement dépendre d'où tu
habites quoi parce que tu auras
peut-être ça sera peut-être plus
pratique pour toi d'aller à un club
canon peut-être dépendre de ton niveau
de ce que tu cherches c'est juste aller
faire des petites parties amicales si tu
veux des cours si tu veux jouer par
équipe enfin tu vois
pas loin mais je sais pas du tout ce qui
eux ils font en terme de
je connais pas ici mais je connais pas
les mais ça il faudrait aller les voir
et on les appelait voir un peu ce qui
propose donc
si tu veux tu tentes tu tentes cliché
ouais
David
après
moi
non plus
ça me dit rien mais en fait
[Musique]
Tour Eiffel je crois pas que ça en
premier j'en sais rien
aucune idée mais
oui non bon il y a pas mal de clubs à
Paris donc moi je l'avais dit Clichy
je sais plus ce que j'avais écrit mais
il y a aussi une nomade il y avait aussi
le club de Marius bag parce que vous
pensez à une fille aussi mais je crois
que voilà donc voilà je vais pas mal de
choses après je sais pas il y en a plein
que je connais pas non plus on a plein à
Paris que je ne connais pas
salut je propose nul
on dit escargots
dans les compétitions etc mais je ne
sais pas ce que ce que fait un chat club
au niveau des cours au niveau des trucs
je n'en sais rien ça je malheureusement
en fait en gros bon vu le profil
j'imagine il vous faut des clubs
qui
fasse du niveau si ça les amuse mais
c'est pas ce que vous cherchez et qui
propose des cours
justement pour adultes pas que vous
soyez que avec des enfants et un peu en
mode débutant avancé c'est à dire que
des gens qui ont passé beaucoup étudié
les échecs mais qui sont peut-être pas
que débutants avec des bons conseils et
peut-être une aide pour pour peut-être
se lancer un jour en tournoi ou quoi
et en fait c'est un nouveau public quoi
de chaque ça
en gros pendant des décennies les gens
qui allaient dans les clubs d'échec
c'était juste qu'il voulait jouer des
tournois et qui avait déjà travaillé etc
et là en fait il y a tous nos publics un
peu en mode loisirs en fait qui compte
peut-être même pas je tends en fait mais
qui a envie d'un peu mieux jouer faire
des parties rencontré des gens faire des
blites jouer un peu mieux apprendre des
choses et donc effectivement tous les
clubs sont pas mis à jour donc c'est pas
évident à dire mais au pire bon tu peux
juste tester quoi tu regardes un peu sur
soit sur le site de la fédé soit sur sur
le moteur de recherche tu cherches hop
et tu n'hésites pas pousser la porte tu
vas voir comment tu es accueilli ce
qu'ils peuvent te proposer ou pas si les
gens sont sympas c'était mal reçu machin
il revient en plus c'est pas grave et
puis bah à un moment tu vas bien trouver
sur un truc cool quoi
après ça avec le club c'est quand même
plus sympa c'est comme sympa de jouer
enfin moi je préfère largement jouer en
vrai que je joue sur internet ça c'est
clair et net
et voilà quoi
mais après bon nous on a un billet parce
qu'on a appris aux échecs les échecs
comme ça et puis qu'on est petit on
côtoie ça donc pour nous c'est les bras
échecs mais les gens qui ont appris
d'autres manières peut-être pour les
échecs c'est déjà sur internet enfin du
en fait on n'est pas leur place mais oui
moi clairement je préfère mille fois
jouer sur un échiquier entre des gens en
vrai pour discuter avoir une interaction
sociale des choses comme ça et même pour
jouer la partie quoi en fait tu as
ressenti par rapport à l'adversaire
c'est pas juste un échiquier et ta
souris et des mots slip
non mais c'est vrai
émotions différentes quand tu joues etc
rien à voir
et c'est pas le même engagement aussi
les choses enfin oui ça change beaucoup
de choses mais après tu vois j'ai
l'impression qu'on est un peu des
dinosaures penser comme ça parce que tu
as plein de Tournes à main avec
énormément de fric de toute façon qui
qui sont faits en ligne et ça prend un
peu cette voix bon
ah bon à ma grande peine entre
guillemets mais c'est comme ça quoi
c'est juste fou quoi enfin les joueurs
gagnent beaucoup plus d'argent se
mettant sur Internet
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux
Détroit en dessin
pour
menacer pour la justice donc je retourne
là il y aurait soit eu 5
soit d'Albert
voilà je l'ai pas vu mais oui
non mais vaut mieux sinon
et
[Musique]
OK
bon c'est le moment un peu décisif de
cette partie en tout cas
soit il va passer sans concombre
ces petites menaces
depuis non on va refaire un petit tour
au même point donc d'un point d'écart tu
as car on a joué
on va voir si
on trouve autre chose
on avait Kemer qui tourne
je sais pas ce qui va réussir
bon il y a eu H6 de jouer par rapport à
tout à l'heure en gros en terme de
culture
mais ça peut oui ça change un petit truc
quand même
OK
[Musique]
puissance 4 là un petit B5 et on a
toutes les pièces sur la sac
tour à en E8
dame C3 attaque un peu tous les pions il
nous a fait baisser ok
BIM
alors du coup là c'est chaud là il faut
réfléchir et en fait du coup l'idée
c'est qu'on va faire dame G3 à échec et
et presque match encore cavaler G6 parce
que tu vas sur dame
en fait le truc c'est que si on fait
tour aussi on a pas que j'ai 6
voilà en fait ça c'est intéressant ce
que tu dis regardez actuellement là
c'est bon la sonores de jeu mais c'est
plutôt blanc de jouer sur dame G3
le match et vous voyez que dame G3 prend
dame C7 il y aurait de Tours C7
maintenant avec le g.f6 et ben on voit
bien que la tour E7 est attaquée par le
pion F6 si la tour venait en V6 pour pas
être mangé et ben je pourrais faire le
très joli coup dame j'ai trois échec
et menace dame G7
sur cavalier qui se met devant en G6 et
bah du coup j'aurai d'armes prend dames
et 7 et je viendrai la dame donc c'est
intéressant ce qui se passe là parce que
là du coup il faut trouver une un coup
après encore une fois j'ai quand même
plein de pions pour la qualité comme on
l'a dit donc même cavaliers maintenant
puis on prend le 7 peut-être un coup
possible
ouais ouais bon on a un peu le rap après
un couple peut-être à regarder c'est
qu'elle F3
je sais pas juste pour voir
l'idée c'est de faire
un chèque en fait on fait échec il y a
pas droit à deux
et il y avait pas de tour Eiffel et donc
pour l'instant il n'y a pas encore de
maths contre le renard bon évidemment
c'est chaud
mais c'était je sais pas c'était juste
pour regarder parce que ça au moins ça
évite de perdre la qualité
bon est-ce que ça donne
avoir mais bon peut-être on peut tout
échanger en F1 on reste avec un pion de
plus on va mettre le rond-point
S
bon moi je crois que j'irai là-dessus
tout est changé mais bon pourquoi pas
faire faire la suite d'abord que de
toute façon je fais un cloué il va pas
s'en aller
et ce qu'on a un coup plus menaçant
je sais pas
il y a peut-être dame
non ça marche pas
un chèque déjà mais même enfin s'il y
avait pas échec
mais bon ça peut pas manger de pain en
fait de pas bouffer une pièce clouée
en F1 on la mange qu'on peut quand on
veut et le fait de faire parachute ça
anticipe un ancien un échec qui peut
arriver quoi
mais position en tout cas très tendu il
y a un seul pion de plus du coup pour
les blancs donc Gims qui récupère un
pion
mais les deux rois sont à poils
bon ok il est caché sur la colonne enfin
il y a plus d'échec sur la colonne il y
a des maths du couloir qui peut arriver
quoi
que le fou F1 est cloué la tour F3 et tu
as la défense du foie F1 donc même si
les blancs d'être actif avec la dame
c'est 3 la tour de 5 et ben au final
c'est pas simple non parce que du coup
ben j'ai quand même ces deux pièces là
qui sont à défense du roi que si Madame
peut pas loin et puis comme tu l'as dit
aussi
mais je suis content que tu es noir de
votre G5 quelque part parce que il
s'éloigne un peu de cette zone
d'influence
un gros problème je prends tout en F1 F4
non
[Musique]
ça a l'air
donc elle est blanc c'est chaud en fait
faut déjà survivre c'est pas facile
mais c'est à deux doigts de juste perdre
sur le champ quoi enfin en fait si
tu dois tourner deux la position elle
est plus ouais
mais je vois pas de coups d'attaque et
c'est juste très chiant ça échec et le
roi bouger il va perdre le feu
l'intercept de l'action de la tour F3
soit il va avoir H1 et il défend plus le
fou donc
donc ton jeu c'est vraiment une menace
et on est cloué et
c'est un problème et Tanger 5 c'était le
coup logique qui bloque la colonne g
garde la tour sur une colonne ouvertes
peut-être on pourra penser à faire
tourger 7 dame C2 un jour aller mater
mais sauf que a priori on se fait tout
bouffer en F1 et on se prend une double
attaque à la fin
donc en fait il y avait ouais c'était
vraiment fallait survivre mais il y
avait pas de survie quoi
bravo gueric
qui revient bien là enfin qui qui met la
pression
il a bien détendu alors après tu as la
partie avec un ordi sur à donner là on
l'avait pas et
donc on sait pas trop c'est des coûts
mais c'était une partie difficile parce
que justement on avait dit qu'en
pratique ça a l'air plus facile à jouer
pour les blancs et lui il a su bien
défendre il a pas
une grosse grosse partie de gris qui
revient du coup à hauteur là de Abdou et
du coup et du coup en fait Abdou
Abdou qui va
qui va devoir faire nul pour garder la
tête
exactement où gagner par miracle
alors d'ailleurs
le plus loin qui peut quand même qui a
le droit d'avancer et puis à droite de
partir en A5 à 4 à 3
et comment est-ce que tu progresses avec
les Blancs parce que du coup ils ont
réussi à changer les drames qui fixe un
peu toute la structure et les tours
blanches qui pourraient éventuellement
se mettre sur la 7e
ouais bon toi tu fais un truc tactique
avec les tours sur la 7e et 4 trucs
à part ça
[Musique]
effectivement avant c'est le pion a en
tant que contre jeu c'est pas bête
et si tu fais un truc du genre tour C7
ou tour B7 pour doubler les tours sur la
7e peut-être que je peux le faire tout
recettes ou juste mettre la tour
parce que c'est vrai que de toute façon
ça peut être embêtant
et voilà
techniquement ça peut être chaud parce
que si tu mets un fond à trois
je peux te mettre
d'ailleurs je suis pas sûr
il faut aller en H8 tu au H7 ton projet
7 et
lentement après avec toi
reviens bon disons ok je suis pas sûr
qu'il va en maths mais c'est une idée et
ça pourrait mal tourner un jour ou
l'autre ouais non mais oui
je fais tout recettes
et surtout
ça va
sur Claude tour en dessert franchement
[Musique]
grâce à la pendule plus qu'une minute 20
pour jouer deux coups
pendant que ça va mais oui ils ont deux
coups ils ont de quoi jouer donc bon ça
va et du coup cache à deux minutes donc
il a double du temps
toutes les compétitions
licence
il me semble
donc elle coûte beaucoup moins cher mais
il y a plein de compétitions qui sont du
coup pas ouvertes pour toi donc en fait
ça dépend ce que tu veux faire
tu veux faire un rapide un jour bah tu
prends la licence B ça te coûte je suis
plus genre 5 10 €, un truc comme ça
et si tu veux par contre tu as des Sens
a et ben
ça coûte plus cher mais tu as accès à
toutes les compétitions lentes et tous
les trucs donc ça dépend de ce que tu
veux faire toi et la licence a c'est
vraiment tout autour aussi
[Musique]
bloquer le pion et puis essayer de
l'attaquer petit à petit avec ces quatre
peut-être la deuxième tour en dessin et
peut-être l'encercler ou pas mais bon
bah l'idée c'est toi aussi c'est en
confiance et voilà
qu'est-ce qui va en tout cas il peut pas
jouer pour ton DS pour empêcher ton 6 à
cause du foyer
G4 une possibilité clairement mais j'ai
quatre c'est cool
parce que tu es élimination déjà et puis
tu feras toujours et peut-être à 5 et
Machin et alors ok
être actif
et c'est 5
puis c'est 6 puis tout prendrait 8 il y
a plus le droit dans le carré quoi
juste un échange tout et ça va faire nul
je pense qu'en fait grâce à il essaie de
poser le maximum de problèmes quoi et si
ils jouent comme tout RAV4 tu reprends
F5 tours G6 en fait tous ces change au
fur et à mesure et ça va faire nul et
bon car saigne et c'est quand de gagner
donc
peut-être que c'est juste ce qui va
faire
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé analyse j'ai
essayé salle de classe le problème c'est
que je n'arrive pas à me connecter à
chaise comme c'est juste impossible donc
sinon t'inquiète pas je ce que j'ai
pensé me connecter à un cheesecom et
puis à copier une position le PGN et
puis à mettre puis à mettre j'essayais
mais bon juste c'est pas possible
c'est injouable donc
en tout cas chez moi ça marche pas et je
vois que c'est certaines personnes ça
marche je sais pas mais chez moi ça ne
marche pas du tout
il a poussé le pion à ce qui est pas
idiot
donc bon c'est pas facile de passer ce
barrage alors que le pion a bah il y a
personne devant et puis de deux si on
veut attaquer G6 bah on peut faire et au
racisme et Tauros 6 donc au choix ou les
deux
donc ça doit pas être mal et là ça va
sûrement réfléchir un petit moment
alors note d'été ouais sur le stream en
fait c'est juste que tu as un quart
d'heure de retard sur nous quoi
et donc il est en H5 ce pion
effectivement mais il a un moment il a
mis Sada manger ici s'ils sont fait
échanger et le pion H5 à remanger sur G6
mais tu vois c'est pas qui sont en
résistent maintenant ça veut pas dire
qu'il était pas H5 avant c'est vu qu'il
y a un pion G2 c'est pas le pion g en
fait
c'est le pion H qui s'est transformé en
G6
un petit moment parce que c'est pas une
position simple
je vais réessayer de faire marcher mon
échec et analyse mais
je doute
c'est complètement ça ouais mais bon
nous on y peut rien
être des trucs
c'est mort de chez moi
oh mon bébé c'est quand même le plus
important en fait les gammes toujours
sympa d'avoir un peu les joueurs mais en
soi moi je préfère voir l'échiquier
non mais d'ailleurs ça a été enfin c'est
un des gros problèmes pour le business
des échecs pour les diffuseurs parce
qu'en fait tu peux pas vraiment avoir
les droits là tu as les droits c'est
bien tu es content tu as des images mais
en fait les gens qui veulent suivre les
parties ils suivent juste sur des
échiquiers et ça tu peux pas l'Internet
c'est comme je veux dire dans le sport
quand tu suis les matchs de foot tu as
qu'un diffuseur qui a le rose images et
tu vois le match je m'en fous de c'est
important de voir les actions mais
surtout les sites où on te fait une
retranscription du match à dire machin
et le ballon il part sur le droite
reviens en retrait nana enfin il
t'écrive le match on peut pas
t'interdire de retranscrire un truc que
le mec fasse des commentaires radio que
on t'écrive les commentaires et donc là
aux échecs bah c'est l'équivalent du
Commentaire radio sauf que là on te
montre un échiquier 2D juste on te
retranscrit ce qui se passe donc on te
montre pas mais on te retranscrit mais
on va dire c'est plus important
que d'avoir l'image
mais bon l'image après pour le coup
c'est juste cool enfin c'est simple
c'est toujours sympa de voir un peu
d'image de voir les réactions des
joueurs de voir voilà comment ça se
passe de voir le concours de marge de
voir des choses comme ça mais en soi
ouais le plus important c'est d'avoir le
chien avec la bonne position
bon je crois que j'ai réussi à faire un
truc
bravo
de triche les délais en fait normalement
là c'est juste très étrange qu'on se
rend direct sur l'échiquier parce que en
fait des délais de partout mais en fait
c'est comme nous a filé un lien officiel
où en fait on est sur ce qui se passe
sur l'échiquier en direct
on va retourner un quart d'heure en
retard quoi non parce que je regarde tu
vas voir
smart
phone
pour pour évaluer mais écoute
c'est pas mal dans l'ensemble j'ai envie
de dire
ouais faudrait regarder et faire des
données et voir voir leur niveau de
précision pour avoir l'ordi ou quoi pour
pour répondre scientifiquement parlant
mais vu de loin un peu comme ça sur les
parties je vois pas de par exemple ça
joue trop mal non plus quoi ça va
je suis en train de
content je pense de ce que je fais super
mesdames sont mieux et c'est 5 sur le
coup profondeur 20 donc ouais c'est pas
énorme mais ça m'étonne pas tellement
parce que comme on disait elle a tout
des Noirs à passer qui est plus facile à
pousser que le pion c'est
et
deuxièmement le pion j'ai 6 des blancs
qui était chiant parce qu'il ligotait
les Noirs prenait des cases euro quoi
ils risquent de se faire capturer par
les tours sur la 6e rangée donc quand on
voit tout ça on se dit ouais mais c'est
peut-être plutôt au blanc de fer gaffe
et donc ça me ça m'étonne pas ce que tu
dis
qui trouve ça moins bien vu qu'il y a
unify
on peut préférer un plateau qu'un autre
et ça je peux l'entendre c'est vrai que
pour nous les français ou les
francophones et ben ça manque un peu de
ne représentants
mais après d'un point de vue objectif je
trouve le plateau cette année très
équilibré et très bien parce que il y a
quasiment tous les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux à part des pots on va dire de
l'ancienne génération
est-ce que c'est beau ou pas est-ce que
tu apprécies alors je sais pas si je
vois enfin je vois un échiquier de chez
com ah il me regarde le live
ok
je vous ai mis la position en direct que
je dois faire à la main du coup
tous les meilleurs mondiaux tu as un peu
les anciens tu as un petit Aronian qui
part là etc ils ont quand même pris les
jeunes les meilleurs jeunes donc les
Indiens
ouais ouais c'est joli c'est joli
à faire
il y a gamer qui est là aussi donc donc
ok c'est cool
et en fait c'est ce que je reprochais
entre guillemets à trop de tendre de
voir toujours le même plateau je vais
m'intégrer les jeunes etc etc donc là
moi je peux pas me plaindre parce que
avec moi-même donc j'ai rien à dire de
là-dessus je trouve le plateau très bien
donc après on peut toujours chipoter sur
un joueur plutôt qu'un autre ou quoi
mais dans l'ensemble c'est si bien pensé
de la part des organisateurs etc donc
évidemment on peut regretter son absence
parce que lui il est et jeune et top
niveau mais en fait je sais pas enfin
c'est lui qui a refait de jouer plutôt
qu'il a pas été invité
Maxime je sais pas pour le coup mais
peut-être que juste cette année ils
l'ont pas invité parce que bah comme il
y a des nouveaux joueurs ils peuvent pas
prendre tout le monde non plus ou alors
Maxime parfait je voilà ça je suis pas
au courant je sais pas quoi dire et
voilà et puis pour les carreaux bah
c'est pas si étonnant parce qu'en fait
il joue quasiment plus de partie longue
l'an dernier il avait juste fait un peu
les Grands Prix et c'était qualifié pour
les candidats peut-être un peu à sa
surprise d'ailleurs bah du coup il est
qualifié il allait tenter sa chance et
puis c'est bien défendu et bien joué
candidat
[Musique]
il a fini quoi troisième je crois au 4e
enfin bon c'est pas mal joué alors ça
fait fonctionner comment les invitations
bah l'ordinateur qui
c'est lui qui décide en fait qu'il a
envie de voir dans son tournoi après
donc il propose aux joueurs et c'est à
eux d'accepter ou pas ce qu'on leur
offre c'est à dire que par exemple si tu
caresses tu lis pas tiens ça te dit tout
le temps non lui dit oui pourquoi pas
enfin mes questions donc tu dois lui
proposer une certaine somme d'argent
tu payes l'hôtel tu payes la bouffe
peut-être tu payes une autre chambre en
plus pour 16 secondes sa famille pour je
sais pas qui enfin après ça se négocie
quoi mais ça marche comme ça en gros
l'organisateur c'est lui qui décide de
base en se disant ouais j'aimerais bien
qu'il y a un tel un tel untel il propose
ce qui veut offrir
accepter c'est pas accepter sa négocie
ça négocie pas j'en sais rien après
il est à ça avec Arsène il va pas jouer
gratuit
donc
payer
ça vaut quelque chose d'avoir son
tournoi l'image de Carson ou quoi
même moi qui suis loin d'eux je vais pas
venir joindre à mes frères en général
donc moi je voilà donc déjà six mois
j'ai des je demande des choses j'imagine
pas les mecs de ce niveau
[Musique]
de prix par tournoi il y en avait un par
mois et juste les mecs étaient chez eux
tranquille tu vois ils vont pas aller se
faire des frais partir 2 semaines loin
de chez eux machin pour
pour rien donc
non non c'est ils ont de super enfin je
pense mais je sais pas ça ok ça
demandera des études mais que les échecs
c'est un des sports si on appelle ça un
sport ça c'est comme on veut ou les
joueurs sont le mieux payés par rapport
à
au public
que en fait on parle de gens qui gagnent
peut-être des millions par an ou pas
loin
pour pas tellement de visibilité quoi
donc clairement les joueurs de l'élite
ils sont non ils sont très bien payés
après c'est pas le cas sur le niveau en
dessous dès que tu descends un peu bah
c'est plus sa vie et puis descends pas
plus c'est vraiment dur et puis bah
c'est en gros tu gagnes plus ta vie en
jouant donc tu peux jouer un peu etc
mais tu dois donner des cours tu vas
faire d'autres choses à côté mais
le top top niveau
est-ce qu'ils sont payés en liquide pour
venir c'est uniquement non mais c'est
des vrais contrastiniers il y a des
c'est très pro enfin on parle de ça
c'est pas tiens je te file 500 et tu
viens c'est
du 50 000 même plus c'est même pas moi
j'ai jamais été en contact pour
l'inviter à n'importe enfin je suis pas
organisateur donc mais 50
000 c'est ils vont pas faire des
tractations liquide enfin non c'est très
officiel etc enfin je pense que Carlsen
pour pour participer au tournoi des
tailles ils gagnent déjà un premier prix
mais a priori je pense gagne déjà le
premier prix et puis après il joue pour
gagner une toute deuxième fois le prix
du monde c'est voilà je pense que
Nakamura il pourrait négocier un prix
très très élevé aussi sachant que lui
quand il joue ben tu sais que
l'événement il va être très très bien
peut-être
très clairement
ouais ouais non mais il y a tout ça à
côté enfin je veux dire après faut être
top combien pour gagner sa vie vivement
souhaitant parce que bon globalement
Top 50 enfin plus tu es proche du top 1
et plus tu viennes très bien ta vie et
puis tu t'éloignes juste tu vis mais
est-ce que c'est très bien c'est autre
chose mais après ça dépend aussi d'où tu
viens parce que en fait genre si tu es
dans un pays très dense où il y a plein
de fois grands maîtres peut-être que tu
es 2680 et qu'en fait tu es nul entre
guillemets pour ton pays alors dans un
autre et une [ __ ] de star et tu as
plein d'avantages et une star nationale
donc ça dépend aussi ça genre je veux
dire
ouais tu vois un russe à 2650 c'est
genre personne enfin il s'en fiche ils
en ont d'autres
alors que c'était si tu as ce niveau là
que ce soit en France ou en Espagne ou
dans plein de pays bah déjà tu auras
l'équipe nationale tu peux prétendre au
titre national tu vas avoir des demandes
pour faire des exhibitions des
simultanés des machins etc donc en fait
déjà selon où tu habites et d'où tu
viens ça va fluctuer
donc voilà donc du radir tu vois enfin
il y a pas de règle mais bon je pense
que oui top 100 mondial ça va tu t'en
sors quand même tu dis quoi
qu'on nous disait ouais c'était belle
c'est le meilleur joueur exactement et
donc donc c'était ton national de ton
pays bah c'est pas mal parce que tu as
les olympiations le batican bien payé
pour jouer aux Olympiques bien ou pas ça
dépend les pays mais tu es payé
[Musique]
un peu une popularité nationale donc on
va peut-être te faire faire des
exhibitions des choses comme ça quand tu
as joué les interclubs tu vas être
quelqu'un de très rare donc on va un peu
s'arracher tes services à te proposer tu
vas y avoir un marché où ça va être cool
de t'avoir dans l'équipe parce que aux
échecs
selon les pays mais en général pendant
en France le Top 16 ou enfin n'importe
quelle division tu as le droit de jouer
que avec trois étrangers sur 8 donc en
fait il y a quand même encore pas mal de
place pour les joueurs français et donc
forcément ça fait monter leur valeur etc
donc tu vois ce que je veux dire selon
piloter ça va être un peu différent
bref donc pour en venir à la position
qu'on a là
il y a le Piona qui continue sa petite
course qui reste d'avancer alors l'autre
option pour le nord c'est d'aller
chercher G6
ça va dépendre en fait si vous cache est
ambitieux ou pas c'est parti
[Musique]
on va essayer
3 qui peut faire peur
enfin je veux dire c'est peut-être la
même chose ça peut être la même mais ok
toi aussi
donc on va sacrifier on va
liquidera ça il mangera on mangera ça
fera
[Musique]
si je fais échec voilà ça là j'ai pas
trop simple comme tout à l'heure mais
toi chaque bois ça fait un peu peur
quand même mais faut voir je suis à deux
[Musique]
c'est dommage
mais du coup peut-être qu'une nulle
Express va arriver ici mais est-ce que
bon est-ce que les gens peuvent faire
mieux que ça après c'est une question
mais en fait c'est vrai que pousser le
pion a on se dit que ça doit être salé
de faire ça d'aller bouffer F5 et puis
bah du coup en plus
[Musique]
mais bon
mais en fait tu vas sur A4 c'est sûr
qu'il va prendre F5 il peut pas jouer
tour des cinq pour ne pas prendre F5 si
on lui laisse c'est trois tours
en fait dès que je vois le coup jouer si
tu veux sur le chéquier en direct et ben
je le joue donc là vous avez à droite
l'échiquier de du vrai direct
du coup ça me permet de pas
là je fais des flèches c'est cool je
peux analyser un peu
voilà l'inconvénient c'est qu'on va plus
les caméras mais
on avait dit
bah oui bon après bon
ça bug complet malheureusement je peux
vraiment
je peux vraiment vraiment rien faire là
je suis en train de ça marche vraiment
pas du tout
non mais ouais ben on fait on fait ce
qu'on peut on y va
mais c'est vrai que des fois c'est pas
facile
et alors moi je vois qu'il y a eu à 4
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne l'a pas sorti
est-ce qu'on voit au pas sur le stream
qu'il a joué
ok
[Musique]
de faire nul peut-être la nul comme on
l'a vu ici
ça risque d'être joué sûrement
donc on avait la partie de Abdou je vais
faire un petit peu
évolué
[Musique]
un petit peu il est tombé deux et le
cavalier 3
tours B3 il échec et orange 7 il y a le
tour des 7 les rois F6
donc voilà
pas simple de passer mais
c'est clair qu'un petit pressing quand
même
c'est pas évident
la première fois qu'il a un peu mal du
tournoi ou pas
[Musique]
de mémoire je l'ai pas trop vu souffrir
en fait
alors ce que je peux faire qu'un Evan
m'a fait penser à un truc je vais être
fantastique aujourd'hui niveau
je vais vous faire des trucs vous allez
voir
je crois que vous allez être
fier de moi
cette caméra
vous allez être fier de moi vous allez
me féliciter je crois
[Musique]
enfin un truc bien propre
il y a pas encore comme partie
[Musique]
après bon enfin déçu il a fait sa partie
Magnus en face il lui répondant et
c'était une partie il a pas fait nul
trop vite quoi enfin la partie va dire
une quarantaine de coups Kesh la cette
fois elle a bien tenu avec ça
c'est pas donné à tout le monde et du
coup bah ça sera ça va lui donner du
baume au coeur sûrement que sa victoire
la ronde d'avant là avec les gens de
repos cumulés
et donc voilà ce qu'il y a pas de toute
façon il y a pas de points facile je
viens même les les plus petits et l'eau
et
donc
oui Carlton tient plus mais en même
temps tu vois c'est pas lui qui a fait
une partie dégueulasse quoi c'est bien
joué il a bien joué
voilà je vous ai mis une petite une
petite caméra en fait ce que j'ai fait
tu vois
[Musique]
j'ai les trois parties et on peut
switcher avec toutes les caméras tu vois
j'ai 47
[Musique]
et du coup je peux aussi tout enlever
pour qu'on ne voit nous donc en fait
voilà je pourrais mettre les caméras
s'il le faut
vous avez les chéquiers en live vous
avez notre analyse aussi
et puis c'est vraiment du bricolage
c'est bien
le Grand Échiquier c'est le live non le
live
en bas à droite
d'analyse donc là on voit qu'on a la
même position il va en avoir tout à 7
donc on va jouer nous-même
je vois bien ça quoi répondez pas mais
forcément si on me parle de robinet de
Cayenne